está comenzando todos los asistentes están en modo de sólo escucha qué tal
muy buenas tardes cómo estáis saludas sergi sánchez para hacer la última clase
de el curso de trading algoritmico de ser sán sistemas que ya era hora que
ya era hora bien bien bueno como sabéis tuvimos que aplazar la clase antes que
nada antes que nada el rigor todo el mundo me escucha bien lo voy a escribir
aquí a ver se escucha la tarda si por aquí me escuchan
no voy a decir nada que eso se está se está grabando y voy a decirte algo
José Loret y va a decirte algo ya me imagino que te imaginas por dónde pero
bueno me voy a aguantar que esto se graba esto se graba por cierto se está
grabando vamos a verificarlo efectivamente efectivamente se está se
está grabando se está grabando porque ahora el antivirus me va a estar aquí
pipa todo el mundo bien se en él no quiere ser que no que no me oyes o que
pesa o es es chiste es chisto o no me oyes en él a ver vamos a ver si todo
bien todo bien por aquí bueno nada como os comenté tuve que aplazar la
clase estamos mejor estoy todavía aunque la voz yo creo que ya se me debe
notar bien confío todavía tengo un poco de todos y así que vamos a ver qué tal
afrontamos las las tres horas vamos que trabajo pero como siempre bueno como
casi siempre vamos a empezar a empezar con las preguntas y en este caso las
preguntas me irán llevando a tratar algunos temas de acuerdo que es un poco
completamente además también hay más cosas tengo tengo material de los cod que
os voy a dar como ya os había decidido vamos a dar todo lo que tenemos de los
cod os lo voy a explicar sin pseudo código porque esto podemos decir que es
bonus es bonus y vamos a también a daros un código que hemos hecho para
sobre regímenes de mercado y demás que era algo también pedido basado sobre
todo en volatilidad donde ahí sí que aportamos algo yo creo interesante bueno
aportamos es algo que no es que no lo hemos inventado nosotros es decir al
final se trata de como ya sabéis y que se puede inventar claro que sí pero pero
se ha comentado mil veces que con los libros con lo que existe realmente todo
hay mil cosas que son totalmente funcionales y operables que ya existen
al alcance de todo el mundo no hace falta complicarse demasiado la vida
venga entonces empezamos como os digo por las preguntas antes comentaros
comentaros que en principio tenemos previsto para el 1 de julio borrar lo
que está en el discord como como material no estaba compartiendo la
pantalla no pasa nada no pasa nada porque simplemente estaba el logotipo
del curso pero ahora ahora me he dado cuenta entonces ahora vamos a hacerlo
a hacerlo estaba la criatura ahora ya vamos con él con el disco vamos con él
con el disco y con las preguntas que yo tengo aquí nos comentaba nos comentaba
que bien ya en el curso alguna vez lo comentado al final el hecho de
dedicarlos a esto estar todo el día peleándolos con el trading operativa
carteras en vivo etcétera al final pues hace que nosamos unos profesores al uso
en el sentido que nuestro tiempo puede estar todo dedicado al curso eso pues
plantea que el material lo subimos lento y estas cosas así que nos hemos dado
cuenta en estas en estos días que nos dimos de un mes para hacer preguntas y
demás bueno para que podrías acabar el temario con calma etcétera que está
todo muy mal ordenado y lo que vamos a hacer es la parte de material la
volgaremos esto en principio planeamos hacerlo el 1 de julio para volverlo a
subir todo ordenado el acuerdo ordenado y bien clasificado es un poco la idea
esto se hará a partir del 1 de julio para que el que ya lo está siguiendo
así pues ahora no le rompa todo pero que estará todo es simplemente se va a
ordenar se va a ordenar por clase de orilla práctica hacer un poquito más
como debe ser para que ya quede ahí como el repositorio para alumnos pues como
como tiene que ser repito y luego también recordar que los que ya estáis
a fecha de hoy en el curso
como mínimo a partir de hoy es decir el 18 de junio del 25 tendréis acceso a
todo de acuerdo como mínimo que incluido a lo que está en el disco
incluido a los vídeos como mínimo un año desde desde acabar que sois los
primeros y tenéis ese beneficio del futuro pues a partir de mañana podemos
redefinir porque de verdad que no lo hemos hecho tener claro 100% cómo como
quedará como quedará pues el nivel de estructura de precios etcétera ya
veremos ya veremos vale en el producto futuro pero
como digo vosotros tenéis un año mínimo de acceso
al final de la clase ya ya os llegó por error como os comenté pero volverá
a llegar la encuesta pido por favor que la que la respondáis al final os
volveré a recordar porque nos ayuda mucho y ya sea hoy sea mañana cuando sea
pues por favor responder la cuesta que es breve hay una cajita para comentar
escribir lo que queráis escribir escribir lo que conseguiréis de acuerdo
sea positivo sea negativo lo que queráis para eso para eso son las las
encuestas vale y ahora vamos con las las preguntas algunas he ido
respondiendo pensando lo hecho realmente un poco para mí porque así me ayudaba a
tenerlo planteado ya las que llegaron ayer pues ya las he dejado porque
quedan aquí abajo pero era un poco para saber dónde tenía yo que bien lo que
comentó el sector algunas cosas voy a decidir otras más otras os voy a dar
fuentes de búsqueda hay general hay algunas preguntas de 3 station las
preguntas de 3 station pero no que las hagáis ningún problema en que las
hagáis pero no es un objeto específicamente del curso y de casi lo
que habéis hecho hay bastante fuente ya disponible os la voy a dar entonces
tanto en el curso como material nuestro que se ha hecho en la web entonces
si queréis mejorar los a formación de 3 station es perfecto es adecuado es
necesario de acuerdo manejar bien las plataformas pero hay otros sitios donde
hacerlo y ahora ya os diré pero contestó ahora el contexto vale
comentaba bisector respecto a respecto a cómo a añadir los datos esto en los
strategy groups se hace aquí acuerdo aquí añades el data el data 2 data 3
sobres añades y lo defines data símbolo buscas o lo escribes vale símbolo que
sea etcétera lo tienes que configurar aquí ya está sin más no tiene no tiene
más acuerdos el data va aquí tú tienes aquí tu símbolo list con tu historia
estrategia y aquí tienes tu adicional data adicional data data series vale
tenía este que era uno que hicimos aquí aquí está vale aquí en las 100 esto lo
hicimos en las primeras clases y aquí se hubiera hecho falta un dado os lo
puedes lo puedes meter
ya está maestro yo os comenté maestro está bien tiene sus cosas buenas pero
tienes cosas malas yo sigo recomendando ya sé que se implica un cierto coste
puede que haya gratis no no conozco lógicamente todo el mercado porque al
final no está con sus cosas y no siempre estás al día de todo lo que sale no
pero pero yo de lo que conozco me sea os recomiendo os conseguimos un descuento
ahí que no estaba que no estaba mal del cual no tenemos absolutamente ningún
solo beneficio y os recomiendo os recomiendo porque es un programa como
ya habéis visto tanto en la teoría como en la práctica bastante potente para
esta parte de gestión monetaria por folio y demás que las hay más potentes
y claro más potentes y puedes buscar en internet encontraréis pero pero está
bien de acuerdo está bien sobre todo para
para iniciar para iniciarse y para tampoco para
ya digo nosotros lo usamos también usamos por folio trader tenemos cual
analyzer lo usamos poco pero planeamos usarlo en el curso lo hemos visto no sé
si algo nada pero lo tenemos pero no no lo usamos mucho pero tenemos pendiente
tenemos pendiente revisar otra vez web lab yo os lo comenté porque es un
programa muy bueno pero hoy en día lo que más usamos pues es maestro ese
por folio trader y excel y msa es un poco el mix que usamos más para para
nivel de por folio creo que no se me está olvidando algo se me olvida algo
me lo indique alberto
pero no es maestro al final os vais a yo os lo digo os vais a desesperar cien
por ciento en algún momento entonces está bien que la conozcáis está bien que lo
trabajéis porque al final tiene sus cosas buenas y por qué no usarlas pero
tiene como os comenté es una software demasiado de antiguo y lento que es
idéntico los materiales que os pasé y los vídeos y aprovecho para introducir
eso de nuestra web esto ya os lo ya os lo os lo comenté
pero brevemente aquí en formación acordaros que hay todo esto de aprende
a usar tres sesiones securities vale esto
aprende a usar este vídeo de tres es obligatorio verlo lo toca bastante todo
le voy a quitar el sonido y lo toca bastante todo es verdad que se centra
en toda la plataforma pero bueno pues interface de estos temas y no sé si
llega a tocar algo de maestro no creo que aquí no pero esa es justamente lo que
os digo en aprende a usar tres sesiones 9.5 las lecciones que son de world
forward y maestro prácticamente hay cero cambios es decir puede haber un micro
cambio de verdad entonces todo lo que es el vídeo
6 algo pero no mucho tampoco 5 5 5 gráficos a ese que hay cambios
el 6 el 6 es lo puedes ver y no y sobre todo los perdón me estaba confundiendo
los los guáminas nuestros quería ir ahí me equivocaba aquí sobre todo ver el
vídeo de aunque repito que los que los que están ahí de jesús nada referentes a
world forward y demás vale pero creo que son los 6 en los nuestros aquí sí que si
ves los primeros lo verás todo muy distinto porque es no y medio pero a la
que llegues a la parte de el 6 donde aquí hablo de algo de world forward y
maestro y creo que el 7 también exactamente el 7 sobre todo el 7 sobre
todo es súper parecido es súper parecido de verdad pero extremadamente
parecido entonces ver este vídeo vale ver este vídeo luego en la web también
de en youtube en el canal de youtube de tristation en el canal de tristation de
youtube ellos hacen vídeos totalmente la mayoría en inglés eso sí sabéis que
youtube la mayoría puede traducir mejor lo hará peor pero hay vídeos de youtube
ordenado de la plataforma bastante bastante apañado vale y van haciendo
ellos contenido formativo con lo cual lo mismo por supuesto esto como os digo
esto claro no podemos hacer un curso al uso de tristation porque si no pues
estamos horas y horas solo eso de vídeo creo que sólo hablando de world forward y
maestro y obviamente no lo toqué absolutamente en profundidad bastante
bien pero eran tres horas y entonces claro al final no no no es aquí tú si
tú vas a listas hay algunos ves ya ordenaditos tienes aquí el platform
training tienes el getting started que esos son esta serie de vídeos que veis
de que habéis visto allí es esto se llaman que tiene que estar de cómo
empezar y ahí lo tienes un poco todo y más avanzando y me imagino que habrá
alguno bueno los caros y no buscáis maestro tristation
pero ya digo ellos tienen bastante bastante bastante material bastante
material aquí sobre sobre la forma que buscarlo lógicamente pero pero lo tenéis
si alguien no lo encuentra lo puedo
que ya os lo dirigiré porque realmente tenemos algunos enlaces guardados pero
no los había preparado porque son antiguos entonces yo creo que es mejor
buscar los nuevos es mejor buscar buscar los nuevos que buscar los antiguos
pero si hace falta pues ya digo los los buscamos nosotros
entonces eso eso sería por una por una parte
tema de también hablaba bisector y creo que alguien más en algún otro caso nos
habéis hablado tema de cartera tema de porfolio vale entonces ahí sí que
quería ver ver algo bueno segundo que le pregunto una cosa al ver no no porque
teníamos claro esto solo valdrá para que tenga que tenga multichars pero pero
como tenemos el porfolio aquel que os enseñamos de último de multichars
teníamos pensado subirlo esto lo lo subiremos vale de por folio trade que
lo que no tenga multichars no le va a servir pero ya que no tenemos y la
material del curso lo teníamos intención de subirlo vale entonces
sobre esto el porfolio si que ha hecho un poquito os quería enseñar hoy
algunas algunas cosas nos quería enseñar algunas cosas que tenía aquí
preparadas vale un segundín que no las tenía ahora abiertas porque he iniciado
antes de abrir para evitar pues problemas
lo busco y sin más material esto estaba un segundín bueno hecho un pequeño un
pequeño ejercicio sencillo en excel vale para mostrar un poco también como
como hicimos bastante en la teoría o con las cosas más no recuerdo tanto
herramientas porque las herramientas se pueden tener se pueden no tener y de
hecho este documento que os enseño y ahora y tenía el las y cable 2007 tenía
un tocho también espectacular se lo puedo enseñar
esto era una de las hojas que cada día revisábamos del fondo no teníamos con
esfera desde la fecha de noviembre del 20 los precios son de entonces y con esto
lo íbamos controlando teníamos aquí un poco esto era el supervisión vale con
los drawdowns de esperados etcétera ratios o esperado eran hojas que
teníamos lógicamente teníamos los software pero aquí teníamos en excel
donde calculábamos un poquito el apalancamiento para sobre todo el tema
regulatorio porque ahí tienes unos compromisos de volatilidad los
compromisos de bar y vamos monitorizando para que no nos desviáramos vale y a
raíz de esto he querido mostraros pues un poco unos ejemplos porque lo creo
que habrá otra pregunta en esta línea ya introduzco el tema ahora vale referido
a esto a vale cómo configurar el monimaran asme y cómo hablar de la
cartera etcétera vale esto donde más lo vimos sobre todo era en msa donde más
lo vimos en msa yo os enseñe que incluso puedes optimizarlos y os digo os
dije que sí que se optimizaba pero que lo cual no quería decir que usáramos
directamente lo que se acaba el optimizador pero si os acordáis porque
esto en algunas preguntas que me habéis insistido
no sé si esa clase no se ha visto no se ha entendido no no no lo sé exactamente
pero pero esto se hizo de acuerdo esto se hizo vale
un segundo se uso se hizo con ésta este un portfolio que montamos de además
sistemas reales de la operativa muestra que os lo comenté apollo nemesis de
casos reales vale con eso sigamos trabajando hemos el optimizador aquí un
poco esta es una herramienta con la que tú al final puedes ver los pesos aquí en
aquí están todos iguales que hablamos si os acordáis de la cual wait os dije y
aquí he contestado un poco en el chat también que un poco lo que yo os
recomiendo hay muchas metodologías y algunas super complicadas y historias y
conexas se puede hacer hasta con solver pero de verdad que no os aconsejo
complicaros tanto la vida el porfolio es evidentemente san dio cuando he
insistido mucho en eso creo que en decir que santo crea del porfolio creo que
algunos habéis interpretado que os iba a dar algo a nivel de porfolio super
especial alguna teoría no lo que simplemente os vamos a dar sí que
trabajamos bastante el money management que no deja de ser parte del porfolio
recordar riesgos exposición diversificación final la exposición es
el cuántos el money management y la diversificación es el porfolio y los
dos trabajan un poco de la mano entonces esa es la idea la idea es que
yo cuando mezclo estrategias mejoró la cartera de manera dramática incluso con
tres que es un ejemplo que os he puesto ahora entonces y esto es así lo habéis
visto en la teoría os hice una práctica también el ejemplo que os enseñé de
una ponencia que ha hecho robotiles los distintos sistemas de la curva como
mejoraba con un sistema con dos hablando recuerdo que práctica era
seguramente la hace dos hace dos donde vimos todo este efecto pues esta es la
la idea que tiene que quedar bien dicho esto es muy pertinente decir cómo
decidir el peso de cada sistema esto está muy bien yo os recomiendo porque
sobre todo al principio no vais a tener ojalá tengáis una cuenta de cinco
millones de euros si es así pues me llamáis y hoy ya llegamos a un tipo de
acuerdo vale pero si al final les vamos a hablar de lo normal que sean cuentas
pues a nivel usuario no vas a poder tampoco abrir sobre todo si vamos por
futuros que es preferible pero como ya hemos comentado tanto en teoría
práctica pueden haber distintos motivos por el que no pueda usar futuros por
ejemplo porque no los tiene el sitio donde me obligan a operar por lo que
sea pero si tú es tu cuenta para ti y tú estás aprendiendo tienes que
aprender a operar en futuros luego ya luego ya irás tú entiendo que quieres
empezar yo y tú quieres operar en dargo nex porque quieres montarte tu dargo y
luego quieres operar en cada lo que sea en otro sitio vale pero lo primero es
que aprendas tú lo primero es que aprendas tú no no vas a poder hacer un
darwin si no eres rentable tú solo antes puedes hacerlo directamente dargo
nex y claro que puedes pero yo creo que te va a ayudar a aprender a operar en
futuros por tu cuenta para eso te puedes servir o dichar interactive
lo que os decía cada sistema lleva su peso lógicamente vale pero en la
práctica 16 opone aquí que vimos porque está el tema de la exposición y es lo
que se había preparado aquí donde está aquí aquí he hecho un supuesto con
ejemplos tipo lo que os enseñaba del fondo si yo tengo una cuenta tengo una
cuenta de 25 mil euros en la cuenta de 100 mil euros
bueno esto es lo que voy a tratar hoy no lo he subido aún porque prefería
enseñarlo aquí luego subirlo porque si lo subo ya lo empecéis a mirar entonces
prefiero subirlo post clase todo lo que voy a enseñar los
hoyos lo voy a subir y va a haber mucho material pero poder acabar las nueve
pero si no seguiremos y lo voy a dar todo pero prefería antes sacarlo
que tenemos tenemos al final un ejemplo de muchos autores otros de hecho también
que al mix sistema activo le llaman vector vale todo esto es un vector
operativa otro vector es igual es un sistema sistema que opera en un activo
pero pero si yo pero el s1 en el mes y luego pero el s1 en el en otro activo
nosotros esto hoy en día lo hacemos como sabéis tenemos ese 1 s2 s3 s4 en el
mismo activo cada uno eso es un vector operativo entonces pero que el nombre es
se entiende la idea yo tengo aquí uno tres vectores tres vectores muy sencillos
esto es una cartera muy real nosotros está esta cartera como está le hemos
operado con además de que enorme éxito y de hecho hubiera sido la primera de
alguna vez hubiéramos podido operarla ya lo sabéis los que nos seguís hemos
puesto aquí el bueno americano pero realmente era con el buen con el bueno
alemán que luego aquí en esta otra lo he puesto pero bueno por por daros
distintas distintas hablar de otras cosas pues pues lo he puesto aquí vale
entonces yo tengo aquí un sistema que va en mes eso es el micro s p fijaros que
el micro s p me pide entre sesión hoy en día de mantenimiento vale 1180 dólares
los he puesto de mantenimiento ignoro las entradas que de hecho son un 10% es
decir esto para abrirlo intradía me están pidiendo 117 dólares yo con 117
dólares puedo abrirlo evidentemente hace falta más en la cuenta pero me
entendéis en un sistema estrictamente intradía donde cierre y garantiza porque
hay unas reglas para eso pero he ignorado esta parte yo he ido a
mantenimiento vale tengo un micro oro que nosotros cuando montamos los lo
tenía aquí de hecho si os habéis bueno os habéis fijado aquí son las reales
bueno aquí estaba este en ese momento concreto estábamos en posición por
eso te podemos llevar tres vale es igual no importa vale la gente de un creo
que podíamos llevar más también
sí porque esto que nominada palenqueamento no estos muy pocos que
llevamos más peso porque este va con micro s p micro nasdaq veis por qué
porque nos granula muy bien pero el oro en ese momento no nos dio confianza de
volumen era muy grande esto te permite diversificar lo peor porque tampoco
teníamos capital hemos tenido pues 20 millones más fácil era un fondo
pero ahora hoy en día el micro tiene bastante volumen vale bastante volumen
ahora os lo voy a enseñar todo esto entonces claro que que problema tienes
pues es este el problema del futuro antiguamente que cada vez se ha ido
reduciendo es que esto un contrato del oro pues puede ser muy grande hasta aquí
uno solo nos copaba 149 mil euros de nominal un 22% cuando en cambio
teníamos 5 s p s micros y era un 13 vale entonces esta es la gracia que
lógicamente ganas menos pero te permite pues repartir mejor tu exposición y en
caso que tengas una cuenta pequeña que es lo normal pues te permite acceder con
una cuenta de 25 mil euros perfectamente a 2 3
estrategias y ha sido súper pesimista con los drawdowns y demás es decir eso se
puede mejorar mucho
entonces yo tengo aquí un sistema en el mes un sistema en el micro oro que pide
solo mil dólares de garantías y tiene volumen a los financiadores volumen y
tengo aquí el bono americano por el tema de divisas podría haber sido otro que
creo que es a cinco años esto recordar que en cualquier otra página yo lo estoy
consultando la de tres sesión por lo que me es muy cómodo pero esto es igual
esto realmente son los datos del mercado normalmente la mayoría de bloques no
piden más que el mercado la que más piden pero en la web del cb también
están especificaciones esto es la parte de la teoría os insistí mucho que esas
cosas hay que mirarlas hay que ser responsables ahora cuando llegue a los
rolos que tengo que explicaros también voy a tratar de acelerar un poco porque
si no hoy acabamos a las 12 de la noche no sería plan porque me voy a quedar aquí
solo entonces aquí tenéis poco las garantías y veis vale bien lo que os
decía los bonos los bonos les interesa es este lfv creo que era si es el cinco
años es el cinco años americano que nos pide mil cuatrocientos dólares y
también nos deja garantías interdiarias al cincuenta por ciento
tres sesión en esto es bastante conservador es un bloqueo conservador no
te da mucho apalancamiento no te da mucho en intradía dices es una putada
bueno si es una putada pero quiere decir que es un bloqueo más seguro al final
si al final todo tiene su su balanza de acordados cuando sale la teoría de los
riesgos no todos los sí podés riesgos que hay bueno el riesgo de que el bloqueo
de quiebre pues bueno pues en tres sesiones menos bastante conservador
más ha llegado a lo mejor pues es más lógicamente siempre será pequeño pero
pero al final pues estas cosas también tienen su importancia
entonces yo aquí tengo una un ejemplo con la manera sencilla de acuerdo de
decidir los pesos por equal waited cuando hablamos de cual waited os dije
igual waited por riesgo igual waited igual waited por por riesgo estoy
intentado acercarme mucho para hablar lo más bajito posible se movió bien verdad
estoy mucho más cerca de lo normal del micro aquí casi besando entonces para
hablar bajito porque creo que así va a ser más fácil que la voz me aguante
entonces bien por un lado como decía tengo el sistema con sus grandes con el
que activo con sus garantías tengo qué capital le tocaría cada sistema porque
si decimos igual waited quiere decir que yo reparto a partes iguales tengo tres
sistemas que decir que a cada sistema para empezar le colocó 20 25 mil entre
tres ocho mil 373 euros eso le colocó cada sistema pero cuando decimos igual
waited por eso que quiere decir tengo que repartir esos ocho mil según el
riesgo de cada estrategia se podría hacer otra manera si si se puede hacer
igual waited por volatilidad igual waited así apelo hay que verlo pero es más
razonable por riesgo es más razonable por riesgo
que a veces a mentir es su hándicap por ejemplo lo vais a ver ahora lo voy a
explicar en los buenos un poco pero porque cada depende del ratio rentabilidad
riesgo que tenga cada sistema pero se puede hacer al mejor también por un
ratio de la vida es decir al final la cuestión es repartir el peso en cada
sistema por alguna métrica que incorpore el riesgo esto usualmente se
hace con el verdadero pero insisto y entender la idea me interesa que
entendáis la idea
y si se hace por lado yo he apuntado aquí un verdadero teórico es razonable
pero es inventado se inventado de cada uno de los sistemas y cada uno de estos
activos al bono le he puesto bastante y es fácilmente mejorable de hecho un
intradía tendría probablemente la mitad o debería de tener la mitad
pero un diario podría tener esto yo he trabajado más o menos contra dos
esperados diarios aquí simplemente sumado que voy a hacer un poco más
grande para ayudar a la lectura porque sé que a veces hay gente que está en
dispositivos no de pc que la verdad recomiendo el curso hacerlo en un pc
al final por mil cosas puede ser que ya no lo pueda entonces voy a tratar de
agrandarlo vale luego ya luego ya cuando vaya a la derecha pues tengo garantías
más nada la sumo y tengo esas cantidades 5.000 euros a bueno porque lo
tengo aquí el cambio rodo le he puesto 1.1 más o menos vale y pues lo he
pasado a euros porque si la cuenta está en euros y sigo operando activos
dólares pues claro peras con manzanas no suman esto ya lo vimos cuando
hacíamos matemáticas en primaria entonces al final he ajustado a euros y
sumo garantías más nada y lo divido por 1.1 que es el cambio euro dólar y tengo
los dos para pasar dólares a euros bien ya sé que cada a este sistema tiene un
riesgo de la manera que lo calculado de 5.000 es el 5.200 5.700
bien y como calculo los contratos pues simplemente dividiendo el capital por eso
sería equal waited a este le tocaría 1.61 1.52 1.23 o problema no se puede
partir un micro bueno el problema es cierto ahí está el problema y ahí es
donde donde realmente las cuentas pequeñas por eso muchas se van a hacer
pedez porque cuesta esto insisto que se puede mejorar porque encima yo sí voy a
ir estrictamente entradía esto lo puedo dejar acordaros en 120 vale y esto a
lo mejor lo puedo dejar en 4.000 entendéis decir que eso al final
perdón equivocado
eso puede dejar en 2.500
es que ya ya este ya podría caberle tres contratos y medio entendéis un poco la
idea no yo lo he hecho estremo para que veáis un caso negativo lo fácil es
ponerlo lo bueno entonces y esto se puede se puede se puede hacer así esto
no es realista eso también realista incluso con 3.000 seguiría cambiando
tres contratos giraros con 25.000 lo bajas aquí a 15 así aún te cabría un
contrato con tres sistemas entonces esa es un poco la idea vale entonces yo
tengo aquí unos 60 unos 50 claro esto en sí yo para que veáis un poco hasta
qué punto es 40 porque estoy hecho así sobre esto es mucho si es muchísimo
esto supone yo aquí redondeado a 1 a 2 y a 1 porque había hecho esto
hacer todo porque no sé si he tocado escrito algo que va a ver a porque no lo
ha actualizado creo que lo que es de la primera versión esto quedaría con 2 y
es igual es igual podría dejar un ojo no vale explico explico el excel vale
explico entonces esto aquí me da simplemente aquí sumo los contratos
totales hago aquí un 100% ahí aquí calculo el porcentaje que supone cada
uno de ellos se entiende un poco la idea entonces mediante este método de
equal weighted por riesgo usando el riesgo de verdad el si el vector 1 tendría
36.8 este 34.8 y 28 bastante parecido a 30 pero podía ser que no en el otro
caso se ha puesto un caso distinto vale luego lo veremos y yo como reparto esto
hombre dices 1 60 pongo o pongo 1 1 pongo 2 esto ya lo veo que esto no
quiere decir que obligatoriamente opere esto pero aquí quiero llegar cuando os
decía no os compliquéis la vida porque al principio sobre todo superáis en
futuros vais a operar un contrato vais a operar un contrato cuando es cuando
tengo que añadir sistemas que alguien me lo decía tengo más dinero que hago si
tiene sistemas añade sistemas y le metes un contrato y entonces que vas a estar
mucho tiempo haciendo eso sistema con contrato sistema con contrato entiendes
porque hasta que no tengas más capital entonces va a ser difícil pero difícil
pero no imposible porque si yo ya puedo meter más los meto los métodos y a
mejor aquí puedo meter otro sb y hacer lo que hacemos nosotros nada se meter
otro vector y repartir los de victor en dos porque me interesa o viendo que tal
dice oye pues yo necesito un intradía puro aquí pues mira vamos a trabajar un
urb como vimos que me cuesta voy a buscar un activo que funcione voy a
buscar un tendencial que cierre que al final no dejas en un ruptura en una
commodity muy muy tendencial como el oro como yo que sé la gasolina como lo que
sea y y ahí pues pero intradía vale voy a ver qué garantías intradías me
deja tres station en cuál me deja más porque no en todos me deja en todos no
me deja en todos es en el que me pide mal no sólo en sp pero luego ya a medida
que voy bajando en commodities no me deja en eurex ahora no me deja antes me
dejaba en en divisas me deja 50% algo es algo en metales me deja 50% bueno algo
es algo en petróleo 25% bueno y algo es algo y ya en agricultura no me deja
nada en esas ya no me deja intradía pero es verdad que normalmente las
garantías son menores son menores luego volveré aquí en esta tabla
eso es un poco la idea entonces yo tengo estos pesos luego yo con mi herramienta
sea maestro sea msa he hecho también optimizaciones de acuerdo he visto
montecarlos he visto cómo que qué hace allí que me elige allí mantiene más
o menos estos pesos no o este lleva 70 y este 20 vale entonces yo aquí mira un
poco la relación que yo quiero mantener que insisto va a ser 1 1
igualmente pero vamos a suponer que no como será en el siguiente lo veremos
pues yo uso esa relación para adaptarla a la cuenta simplemente a mí me interesa
este amarillo de este de este método aquí he hecho un supuesto vale es real
porque me interesa ver el apalancamiento pero esto me interesa el amarillo es mi
punto de partida hay autores que esto lo utilizan de benchmark bien y utilizan
una optimización pero cada una optimización yo os lo he dicho es muy
optimizar siempre es complicado pero en este caso es todavía más porque estás
mezclando sistemas entre sí estamos dando trades continuos y alterar la
distribución de esos muy complicado que sea reproducible y avises cómo cambia
cuando le aplica montecarlo por eso sí que aquí a nivel de porfolio
recomendable usar montecarlo para ser pesimista simplemente a ser pesimista
en sin más como viste es en msa recordaros que eso lo vimos porque al
final es difícil es difícil mantener y a mí la optimización a nivel de porfolio
repito que la hacemos pero digo utilizarla de manera estricta lo que
sale me cuesta optimizar porque al final como hemos hablado ya harto y tendido es
la manera de obtener datos muchas veces de esa manera yo puedo analizar la
información y hacer perfiles y en el porfolio pasa igual puedo hacer
distintas pruebas como vimos en msa le pongo dos o le pongo un uno como se
mueve a montecarlo que pasa y voy viendo cómo se mueve el porfolio haciendo
cambios pues ese sería un punto de partida y a partir de ahí puedo usar
msa para complementarlo para modificarlo ligeramente y ver por dónde van los
tiros y ver qué sistema no mejor pues peca más en montecarlo porque su
distribución de trades pues está muy concentrado tiene muchos negativos
como ya hablamos esto los tendenciales lo sufren y por eso a nivel de montecarlo
por ejemplo los antitenenciales que tienen porcentajes de aciertos más
elevados pues suelen ser más merévolos porque porque no tienen tantos trades
acumulados vale tantos se han acumulados en negativos que no tienen 10 11 12 15
13 seguidos negativos que esto al final te matan cuando pilles un droga y por
eso hace que al final siempre que hay una optimización ahí de money
management normalmente es en un tendencial es más conservador por lo
que os digo porque montecarlo que haces muchas ordenaciones siempre hay alguna
que te destroza que te destrozó entonces única manera de paliarlo es ser
conservador por eso ya digo los antitenciales con porcentajes de acierto
mayores son ser más cómodos
vale entonces aquí he hecho el precio de cierre de ayer de los activos su valor
por punto el big point value lo que vale cada futuro un punto y de ahí sale el
nominal el nominal de un futuro lo que vale un futuro es esto
ahora lo pongo todo a uno esto es lo que vale un ms un micro sp ayer a cierre
27 mil dólares un micro oro vale 23 mil y un bono vale 106 mil aquí hay un
matiz a dar a leyito como se ha anticipado antes un poco que quería
los buenos tienen un problema al final parecen que son pocos rentables porque es
verdad que te copan mucho capital sobre todo si tú vas por exposición claro si
vas por bar ya no importa tanto por eso como nosotros íbamos por bar y algo es
igual pues lo podríamos usar sin problema pero aquí veis lo veis que un
solo contrato y esto al final no tendría una expectativa de beneficio cuatro veces
como parece apuntar su nominal para nada aquí en contratos le sale un peso menor
que éste y aquí fíjate que tiene un nominal de 106 usa mucho capital si yo
voy por nominal como iba en el fondo bueno no en ese no pero había ido en la
seca y no me podía apalancar ese seis tenía que ser uno imaginaros ese seis
tenía que ser uno yo esta cuenta necesitaría que mejor 200 mil he pasado
150 mil euros para operar es en un fondo 160 esto mismo un contrato de cada para
operar un contrato solo de esto en un fondo que no me permita apalancarme
necesitaría 150 mil euros y eso que es micro y micro porque el bono ocupa mucho
es verdad que me permite aunque aquí cambia poco hay veces que en el boom
puede cambiar más porque está un precio mayor este es el cinco años vale bueno
o estaba un precio mayor que han caído muchos los bonus el regulador aquí no
sé si alguien se ha fijado tenía una notita ves aquí en verde que lo pone
ves el boom puede contarse el apalancamiento por nominal del bonos al
regulador te permita contar el futuro por nominal pero eso es un detalle que
si alguien lo ha visto se lo explico es el que es el nominal el nocional 100.000 vale entonces
me permitía que en vez de 106 aquí contarán 100.000 pero en este caso cambia muy poco pero
ha habido momentos donde eso cambia bastante a bajar en 160 y eran 100.000 en vez de 160
entonces eso pues sería suma sumatis pero ahora sí el bono si tú vas por exposición parece que
te ocupa mucho pero no va a ser por exposición superas para ti no va a ser por exposición
superas en dargüenex va a ser por bar y por bar es otra cosa por bar ya puedes hacer te comillas
lo que quieras a este nivel porque a ti te va a contar el riesgo el bar que ya hablamos la teoría
acordaros por daros porque en la práctica no hemos hablado creo demasiado de ello y lo comentábamos
por daros que la manera fácil y rápida de calcular el bar es el bar paramétrico acuerdo el bar
paramétrico vale no es más que la rentabilidad menos el valor zeta que es conocido unos 60
lo vamos a dar lo vamos a dar el de la clase 164 esos valores son conocidos siempre es
igual al 95 164 y el 99 23 te los apuntas en un papel y hasta nos manda que te los calcula el
excel con una forma porque no cambia eso sí asumiendo distribución normal gran pero bueno
suponiendo que yo no tenga la lista de operaciones si yo tengo el retorno medio de un periodo o de
un trade yo tengo en un performance report un sistema yo tengo la verdad straight no sé lo que
un tric puedo esperar de él no 100 dólares 230 bien y será desviación típica si si lo sé todas
las plataformas me lo dan también tres son en trade análisis me da la desviación típica una
desviación pues con eso ya tengo el bar estimado aproximado ya tengo el bar por trade si lo quiero
por día pues necesito los períodos caros y lo quiero por un mes eso ya es otra otra cosa esto
aquel que no se acuerde por favor ver aquel ejercicio donde hablé de todo esto en la teoría
del bar y trabajamos en profundidad con excel súper denso aquellas clases verlas cinco veces
por favor no una ni dos cinco veces con un sistema que calculé el ratio cálculo el bar y aquí lo
calculé ya digo por paramétrico por por por histórico es cierto esto pues repasarlo yo de un
sistema puedo sacar el bar por por haber el straight y si me dan los resultados medios de
un periodo que creo que ahora de memoria hablo multicharts me lo da lo puedo sacar de ese periodo
sólo necesito un retorno medio y una desviación típica no es nada más con eso sacó el bar el
bar paramétrico entonces con eso ya ya tengo ya tengo el bar bueno a lo que nada y lo mismo para
el porfolio necesito la media el porfolio y la desviación típica por folio los daré por operación
si no necesito por tiempo pues tengo que sacar un medida temporal vale entonces automáticamente
yo aquí he sacado simplemente el abancamiento porque es una medida estándar que siempre al
final tiene bien saberlo seis veces abancamiento es abancamiento potente vale potente lo normal
aunque esto depende porque aquí hay la trampa está el bono la trampa está el bono lo normal
en una exposición así es que esto fuera un bar a lo mejor puede ser que fuera menos pero
puede ser mar 15 perfectamente incluso puede que 20 pero yo creo así a ojo que esto estaría por
ahí ese nivel de bar es un bar asumible es un bar fuerte pero asumible y si esto fuera a 50 mil
que con otro sistema de este estilo de este estilo pues sería igual no menos a coño digo
cómo me ha subido que me he puesto un 0 de más sería sólo apalancamiento de 3 eso es un bar
bastante modesto apalancamiento de 3 puede estar alrededor del 5 puede ser bastante en línea de lo
que es el bar de el bar aproximadamente aproximadamente así a ojo estoy haciendo
estimaciones no me lo toméis esto como una sentencia porque no importa simplemente lo doy
como como referencia pero esos son detalles que tratan de ayudaros a responder esa pregunta
reiterada de cómo configuro los pesos como qué estrategia manda bueno manda un poco
a mí me gustaría más hacer una métrica es rentabilidad riesgo bueno es igual al
final va a ser el divisor aquí al final vas a tener un total y al final vas a salir un
porcentaje me entiendes el final es igual el número que salga aquí yo lo voy a sumar y luego
voy a dividir y lo que importa es este valor de peso si aquí es el número de 7 aquí es 8 y aquí
es 9 sale igual el peso entiendes decir este número aquí son contratos pero es igual todo
el final divides el capital que tienes que es el mismo equal weighted vale repartido del
sistema por un variable de principio riesgo pero yo puedo usar otra métrica que sea la misma en
los tres claro porque si no no no estoy mi peras y peras y manzanas y manzanas pero ya está divido
por eso y reparto y yo ya sé que el sistema me compensa más la industria suele hacerlo por
ese variable como os lo he hecho yo pero yo entiendo que también tiene sentido por un ratio de
retorno riesgo que el valor de quien le llamas contrata por el llamas divisor resulta le pones
resultado y ya está y lo que te de aquí tu sacas su porcentaje y ya sabes que al final esa
es la cantidad esa es la cantidad que le tocaría a cada para hacer igual weighted pero por riesgo
entendido y aquí calculado el apalancamiento para una referencia que será apalancamiento
pues simplemente la cuenta partido por el nominal de los futuros el nominal y ya digo
está la trampa está que nos rompe por eso lo puesto expresamente para que evidencia este
problema de los bonos que realmente parece que no compensan y es verdad que si vas a exposición
cuesta que compensen otro ejemplo tenemos una cuenta de 100.000 ya es un poco mayor y aquí
decimos yo tengo 6 6 vectores ahora 6 vectores seguramente podría tener más porque esos sistemas
la mayoría si tú tienes sistemas diarios nos lo comenté nosotros tenemos estudios hechos de
apolo y artemisa en un montón de activos y por eso he insistido hasta hacer muy pesado con total
seguridad que cuando podamos operar en futuro seremos mucho mejor porque yo puedo operar aunque
sí que es verdad que ahora voy a saltar ahí al volumen mira voy a hacerlo ahora porque así vamos
un poco no siguiendo tanto en el excel tanto en el excel tanto en el excel y volvemos un poco
un poco locos a ver
a no tenía aquí abierto matame la pasada como lo he ido abriendo y cerrando al final pensaba que
lo tenía abierto aquí
a no porque lo tenían los los cot igual no no lo tenía otro lo que habrá aquí
abierto es seguro que tenía uno abierto a bueno era este no eso es bueno me puede servir este no
pero voy a abrir el otro tengo dudas de cuál era pero pero voy a abrir el otro yo creo que debe
ser este lo que os decía de los volúmenes y demás vale y la página vale también de cara a elegir
futuros os puse ahí por ejemplo recordaros en el disco algún ejemplo de porfolios de
materias primas que no tiene porque ser solo de eso pero el disco a nosotros aquí no si lo puse
lo puse pero estaba dentro de algo no en esto quizás era esto es esto esto esto que sobre
los porfolios de ejemplos son ejemplos pero esto más allá de ese ejemplo de los poderes o
referencias el que pueda operar futuros es bueno que vosotros miréis esto que yo os que yo os
enseño ahora vale yo tengo aquí una columna en que me dice el volumen medio no sé si tengo de
un mes y tengo aquí el volumen a ver h efectivo que es un indicador hecho por nosotros que
simplemente es el nominal o sea simplemente es multiplicado por el cierre porque porque
depende del coste que que precio tenga un activo pues realmente necesito más dinero menos si solo
cuento el volumen a mí el hecho que un activo pere 50.000 contratos no me dice nada por eso
solo porque depende de cuánto sean a cuánto cotiza si cotiza un dólar a 100 a 100 pues
siempre es más no acuerdo usar usar contratos entonces de esta manera es donde lo tratamos
de calcular entonces fijaros aquí que salen cantidades de dinero muy grandes que nos da
igual pero es una manera de ver de ver un poco los futuros que volumen que volumen tienen de acuerdo
que se han ordenados por esto es un skin que se lo puede hacer cualquiera vale todo esto es
información de la plataforma no es nada especial los símbolos los puedes ir escribiendo y
pero esto ya digo si alguien lo quiere se lo paso también tienes aquí por ejemplo en metales por
ejemplo si es el oro la plata el cobre y tengo el micro oro que como no está el continuo hecho lo
tengo que hacer personalizado porque hay algunos que no tienen continuo hecho que fijaros que
tiene un volumen aún así mayor que el platino vale y con esta información y con las garantías
y también con alguna prueba que yo haga acordaros que miramos con aquel workspace de tendencia en
futuro os acordáis y miramos pues a de x a ver a su volatilidad puedo tener un sistema yo he hecho
cualquiera de los que tengo hecho estándar uno tendencial no tendencial ponerlo hacerle una pequeña
o 10 o sin hacérsela a ver cómo va en un tendencial como bueno tendencial referencias para ver un
poco activos vale maneras sencillas de hacer las cosas porque hay un coeficiente de gilts por
ejemplo que se usa para esto la verdad nos complique es la vida porque no lo vais a sacar
igual así vale entonces por este lado lo que sigo aquí ves un poquito pues qué volumen tienen
y por otro lado pues aquí ves un poquito qué garantías tenemos garantías tenemos por ejemplo
aquí se da una curiosidad que os quiero llamar la atención donde por ejemplo por ejemplo dice
eso mira eso es muy interesante operar la gasolina porque me he hablado muy bien de la gasolina es
verdad muy bien yo sé yo veo que hay un mini de la gasolina en el nímez muy muy interesante con
3400 pero veo algo mejor lo que hay un micro de la gasolina con 660 dólares no esto parece
bastante potente pero voy a probar a ver a ver si lo tengo por aquí ya abierto tengo aquí una
roba mrb mrb que además tiene hasta continuos que maravilla no y resulta que hace dos contratos de
media y eso es así lo he mirado varias veces eso se lo pongo ya en diario ya no no no hace barras
porque el mercado pues saca saca su producto de funcionar o puede no o puede no funcionar
porque a ver podría ser que yo me hubiera otra cosa que tengo por aquí es como ahora mismo no
lo operamos no lo operamos podría ser que tuviera el mes corrido porque por ejemplo el petróleo
tiene y esta manera pues puedo tratar de tratar de verlo así que lo tengo aquí en el sindicador
no pero no me lo va a dar pero sí que sé que tiene 12 meses no se le gira si realmente tiene
tiene 12 es ahora que no que están la n o en la q la n o en la q la letra tiene 12 las energías
suelen tener 12 consultarlo que averiguarlo pero lo tiene entonces cada mes de mes pense pero va
corrido luego cuando nos siguen los rolos vais a ver aquí que es muy interesante porque es ahora acaba
de saltar pero acaba de saltar ahora al q que es el de agosto ha vencido julio ha vencido julio
y ha saltado agosto como por delante ya salíamos en el q vale pero es igual sea n o sea q si yo
vuelvo aquí ahora que vamos a ver ahora porque mejor me he equivocado perfectamente pasar no
encuentre aquí aquí tengo m r eb q 24 abro el vencimiento en curso y habéis que no m r b
n 24 si este no va corrido es julio es que no va corrido igual es que no va corrido hay que hacer
el continuo propio podría pasar porque es muy raro a ver si ahora el m 24 tiene volumen ojalá
tampoco quizá tenga algo más pero ya veis que no hemos mirado junio hemos mirado julio es
mirado agosto no hay más es que septiembre rb m n 1 24 creo que es agosto hay septiembre no
septiembre pues ya está mayo no puede ser no puede ser m rb
es marzo coño h j falta una hora y no sé cuál es m j m j k coño k es que no se operan esos
contratos son muy pocos suaves pero a esa edad tienes algo que se ha equivocado
no tiene volumen es lo que veis aquí efectivamente el continuo que ha hecho
no tiene volumen no es operable entonces está muy chulo en la tabla pero no sirve para nada
entonces pero en cambio como veis aquí en la tabla tenemos el mcl que es el mismo es también
micro petróleo que sí que tiene volumen tiene más volumen que el qm que el mini que esto siempre
cuando empezaron a sacar los micros los mini pensé qué pasaría porque al final yo me puedo
anular mejor entendéis al final saca un euro y hay un euro dólar grande hay un euro dólar
micro es hombre pues el micro es el que más volumen hará porque al final yo me puedo
granular mejor pues no es así en la mayoría de futuros tampoco ha pasado en el taxi que
operan bastante volumen pero no en nominal en nominal no operan cuando haces el cálculo no
operan más no operan más en cambio en el micro petróleo si pasa el micro petróleo de media
mueve 342 mil contratos el qm que es el mini petróleo mueve 41 mil es que el grande mueve
un millón sigue siendo otra liga pero es como veis el micro feles son 2.700.000 es mucho más
pero es más el micro cl multiplicarlo por el valor del futuro es más vale es más por lo tanto está
moviendo más volumen aquí sí que compensaría operar el micro cl que tiene un volumen aceptable
esto lo vamos a ver en un momentito de cinco minutos y vais a ver que es operable en cinco
minutos tengo velas normales en cinco minutos incluso a tener poco volumen a tener poco volumen
son cosas que tengo que mirar pero tiene volumen tiene volumen de por cada cinco minutos 280
contratos 170 400 es un volumen que está bastante bien en un volumen que seguramente es muy superior
al ibex por ejemplo al menos que lo que era no sé cuánto mueve el ibex ahora por contratos
el futuro del ibex en un día pero antiguamente movía a 30.000 no sé no sé hace muchos años
pero está muy bien entonces esto permite que sea operable me interesa el número de contratos
también por eso miro las dos cosas las dos cosas entonces el micro petróleo es muy operable y
cuidado porque el micro petróleo esto me lo he hecho explicar porque quería sólo son 600 dólares
de garantías claro básicamente todo esto voy a ganar menos de con el grande pero lo puedo operar
me entendéis con 600 euros dólares lo puedo operar no me permite garantías
entrariarias pero es que el mantenimiento son 600 son 600 tengo que mirar un poco
tengo que mirar las garantías que tenga volumen etcétera entonces este tipo de tablas me pueden
venir bien para eso tanto volumen como volumen efectivo quedaros en lo en las equity que se
da que el sp la locura tiene 7 millones de contratos diarios el nasdaq tiene el mini nasdaq
que va se usa en el que tiene 3 millones de contratos diarios y el micro nasdaq tiene 5 6
millones mode más muy bien es tremendamente operable lógicamente lógicamente pero tiene
vale menos es decir su volumen efectivo es menor pero oye estamos viendo más volumen en contratos
que en el dax por ejemplo al menos hasta un tipo no pasaba esto está muy bien porque quiere
decir que a mí el mini nasdaq me es totalmente operable que luego a lo mejor por comisiones
es más caro puede ser pero me va a permitir operarlo tengo hasta más contratos en volumen medio el
número de contratos que el nasdaq es el micro nasdaq me viene muy bien vale porque me viene
muy bien porque el nasdaq como no para de subir las garantías van subiendo el nasdaq ya el mini
nasdaq son 17 mil dólares de garantía y lo van a subir en cualquier momento y el micro son 1770 ya
siguen siendo porque antes eran hasta menos de mil casi pero y el micro se ve 1180 que sigue siendo
operable no llega a tantos micros pero tenemos aquí mueve 3 millones al día 7 millones mueve el
grande 3 millones mueve el micro en este caso no están no llega a hacer más claro es que se
opera mucho más el mic el nasdaq que el sp en el micro tiene el doble de contratos casi en nominal
y en el número de contratos y en nominal no en efectivo opera más en el mini se opera más el
sp pero en el micro se opera más el nasdaq entonces bueno esto me viene bien a mí porque puedo
operar perfectamente cualquiera de los dos tienen volumen tienen garantías pequeñas y cuidado que
aquí puedo hacer intradía en este caso sí que puedo con el mic y con el micro nasdaq a un 25%
ya es que no vas a poner nada vale son 400 dólares vale y 177 y en el rase el que todavía
son menos también puedo y son 160 dólares intradía mentalmente estaría inicial con 200
dólares de garantías puedo abrir el gas el micro entonces estos tipos de cosas son las que hay que
mirar y trabajarlas y analizarlas por ejemplo en excel de este tipo vale claro si yo quiero
operar materias primas es lo que hablábamos antes ahí sí que algunos tienen como habéis visto pero
fuera del micro petróleo cuesta encontrar cosas operables es verdad que la mayoría de ellas ya
tienen menos sería una soja o por ejemplo un maíz un corne vale que son 20 millones y 900 mil de
media de media son pocos contralos pero oye no está mal no está mal son más que el md vale el
mid cap es muy grande el mid cap bueno tengo ahí tengo ahí cositas cositas que digo no llegan al
volumen pero se puede aún sobre todo para uno operar pero ahí sí que ya no voy a poder encontrar
porque en el caso que los hubiera que no creo que no los hay la agricultura por ejemplo granos
no va a tener volumen pero es la soft al final aquí sí que la soft sí que pican algunas un poco más
café carros el cacao 14 mil dólares para para abrir un cacao encima no crees que tiene un gran
volumen el cc soft 100 mil de contados al día es un tronco esto es un tronco maco no se puede
operar vale esto sería solo apto para grandes cuentas pero ya digo micro oro bien puedo operar
un micro oro puedo operar un micro oro puedo operar un micro un micro petróleo puedo operar
un micro cobre bueno podría operarlo podría operarlo micro cobre está ahí 60 mil está ahí
podría operarlo ya tengo que mirar qué barra tal podría operarlo a los cinco minutos estoy
todavía en 40 contratos 50 70 mejor en un 100 120 minutos podría operarlo seguramente un micro
cobre vale y ya me pediría un micro cobre podría operar lo que no se irá haciendo
trading el poder operarlo se puede operar todo porque se cotiza se puede operar entiendo yo
si queremos hacer el trading y ahora entraría en diario lo podés operar prácticamente todo todo
lo que habéis visto antes de la gasolina no se entiende pero cualquier cosa que tenga una
barra completa en que visualmente sea completa en 60 minutos es operable en día es decir no
no el problema ya directamente me estoy refiriendo al entraría un cobre pues tiene un volumen
razonable y estamos con un 400 dólares estamos con 400 dólares de garantías es ya no me dejan
entrarías que es muy pequeño y estos son las cosas que uno ya tengo que mirar para definir la
cartera sobre todo cuando es pequeña a ver cómo tal venga voy a meter un bolsa bueno venga pues
oye de si voy más tengo más margen a mejor voy por el micro nasdaq si no tengo tanto porque es
más volátil y además tiene las garantías un poco mayores pero si no pues voy voy con un micro
cp que sólo son 1180 oye si no me meto con un micro raser que está de coña vas a meter con
un micro raser y empezando cuando pueda ya me meto con un micro nasdaq venga vamos a ver un
micro oro y que ahora oye tengo nosotros tenemos eso ahora mismo recordaros en nasdaq a ver un
micro oro cuánto qué garantías tengo y estoy mirando sólo mantenimiento un micro oro venga
con un micro oro voy con mil bueno un poquito más que el otro pero está ahí está ahí oye llamadas
aún me meto un micro petróleo y voy y voy de lujo con un micro petróleo me va a permitir
hasta granularlo porque son 600 dólares sólo entendéis y ya hemos visto ahí minicore minital
sé que hay bueno complicado no van a tener volumen no van a tener volumen casi con total seguridad
me equivoqué porque porque el mercado el cm es una empresa él saca los contratos el mercado pues
se decide lo que hace con ellos pues a lo mejor hay que un tiempo empezar a operarse pero ahora
mismo pues no sé no sé qué micro a ver a ver lo voy a meterlo por aquí brevemente y sigo por otra
cosa aquí data black row el ticket de esto para eso que tenga contigo pero si no lo voy a meter
genérico a ver si me traga lo que sé mini mini corva o mini soy bien no porque el soy bien es
el que más operan ellos va soy bien es y acá y acá y acá vamos con y acá vamos con y acá
no va a tener ni continuo ya veréis no tiro continuo entonces no toca serío
y acá yo que sé igual a 11 o en recé que es uno bastante genérico para el volumen no valer
supongo ya ves 12 contratos inoperable esto es inoperable esto es inoperable a ver esto
podemos mirar también podemos mirar también de hacer a ver las hojas que ahora mismo no me acuerdo
creo que tiene también bastante si bueno puede estar en k n o en q puede estar en k n o en q
vamos a ver en k n o en q y griega k n 24 cuidado cuidado que en julio esto no sea tan mal y griega
el tema es esto hay que mirarlos mirar los vencimientos porque el rolo cuando uno no
lo conoce también puede ser a foros y demás pueden tener distintas características veis
por uso de costumbre por historias que no ahora parece que el front el front es n de hecho aquí
me va a decir el front de las hojas que entiendo que eso debe ser el mismo s n 24 y s x 24 el front
x x 24 y acá es el otro celene celene celene el que hemos visto y griega k n 24 bueno y griega
k n 24 damos en 5 minutos si nos vamos a diario y por cien que esos operable en diario en diario
tenemos mil contratos a ver como tenemos muchos mil contratos son muy pocos incluso mejor semanal
se podría a lo mejor hacer algo a lo mejor hacer algo en caso que sería complicado
sería justo pero poco para que se vea un poco la dinámica la dinámica de ir buscando ir buscando
eso sería un poco lo que quería enseñaros de esta parte de carteras y demás cosas vale este excel
bueno seguramente mañana repito que todo lo que vais a ver hoy en la clase os voy a subir todo
vale bueno a mí no a mí no yo no me voy a subir a mí mismo pero lo otro sí lo otro que veis y
que lo sabía eso entonces sigo del hilo de preguntas de las preguntas que era un poco la
gracia había alguna que era como de incidente y por eso pues vamos a ir volviendo para que
cosas sobre ello si luego me hace falta volver pues ya vuelvo ahora no enredarme bien entonces
esto ligado en sector que ya le contesté un poco aquí
vale el tema de la pregunta 2 3 iba un poquito y 4 vale con el tema money management cartera
la 4 era la sugerencia de porfolio maestro ahí ya un poco lo que de lo que te he dicho antes de
acuerdo aquí ya te puse el link del material que di y te he enseñado antes me ha anticipado quizás
ha enseñado antes la pregunta hay el material de su sitio de nuestra web vale esto te recomiendo
ver estos vídeos ver el 7 no sé si el 6 trate algo pero el 7 si no seguro el 6 y 7 el 7 ya te digo
muy breve aunque tú lo veas que es distinto vas a ver que es que no ha cambiado nada y esto es
el año de la pico ha cambiado ligerísimamente vale en la parte que final igual forward también
alguien hablaba de igual fútbol pues lo mismo aquí lo ves vale aquí lo ves vale eso lo podéis
ver porque de verdad no han cambiado no han cambiado tienen cambios muy muy menores muy muy
muy menores entonces podéis ver aquí y aquí lo explico unido al material que ya subí de porfolio
maestro aquellos pdfs y si no unido a lo mejor algún material de apoyo de lo que se llama de
la web de el canal de youtube de de tres eso vale y si no alguien me insista hoy no encuentro
tal pues yo te lo busco vale pero esto de verdad es más o menos lo mismo es más o menos lo mismo y
hay que hacer pues algún ejercicio y explique cómo funcionaba y demás vale entonces entre esto lo
que había de nava también que os he enseñado vale que ahí creo que toca poco pero si no la
lista buscas el porfolio maestro es lo que te recomiendo ver y lo que ya hemos hecho nosotros
que hicimos de las primeras clases como te comentaba aquí en el en el en el foro la práctica
2 y la 15 16 toqué maestro entonces lo veis más vale lo veis lo veis más y lo del porfolio lo que
os decía que ya te comentaba vale quien 2 3 te añadió un poco vale pero comenté las teorías
la teoría moderna de carteras la post moderna de carteras cuando entras todos estos modelos están
pensados para operativa convencional de acciones y demás al final a la que tú entras en sistemas
donde hay vector largo corto activos distintos todo lo que sale aquí optimizado al final el futuro
no se mantiene cuesta mucho de mantenerse entonces ya yo yo prefiero priorizar la diversificación y
eso como lo hago pues por equal weighted proviso porque si si te dejo optimizar si tú puedes
optimizar te va a pasar al msa verás como alguna vez un sistema le pondrá un 1% y otro un 30% dices
no quiero ellos no quiero porque no estoy diversificando porque porque porque ve que uno
tal lo que te decía uno tiene unos traits es más antitenencial entonces el tenencial el mono de
marás me lo penaliza mucho a la larga no te va a dar buen resultado o no te va a dar mejor resultado
igual weighted o parecido a cual wait de acuerdo es decir luego con msa lo puede retocar pero ese
es el punto de partida el excel que os enseña bien luego al ver comentaba al ver comentaba que
tenía dudas sobre la estrategia 2 las dudas bueno ya te he ido esta guía no has comentado nada más
al ver no sé no sé decirte no sé si vienes un email si sigue sin irte y lo y lo y con nos llamas
y tratamos de hablarlo imposible con la información que me das se me ha ocurrido lo de la low short
se me ha ocurrido esto de aquí no es que no tengas puesto en el short desactivado aquí pero
más que eso no sé no sé decirte vale y bueno luego ya vendía raúl que que vino pues un poco
más un poco más tarde así que no las he llegado a contestar con lo cual perdón a ver estas voy
voy leyendo las y comentó un sistema en diario que opere muy poco menos de 100 operaciones en
20 años aprox pero que he probado maestro es una desagrande tiene un resultado correcto
contra y suficientes se podría dar por operable en un portfolio bien esta tuya te has puesto la
venda antes de la ferida de la de la herida no con esto de que es posible que algunas respuestas
en las prácticas anteriores pero no me ha dado posible repasar no en las prácticas no en la
teoría también en la teoría también vale pero entiendo que preguntes que para eso estamos si
claro que sí claro que un sistema diario que opere menos o poco de 100 operaciones probado en
una cesta grande hecho ese es el camino ahí no vamos a poder optimizar no optimizamos pero lo
que hacemos es validarlo lo hicimos en la primera clase con las 100 con las 100 acciones del nasdaq
y por ejemplo tanto nuestro apolo con los artemisas siguen aunque sí que se pueden optimizar porque
tienen un número suficiente de trades pero aún así se validaron la renovación preliminar en una
cesta muy grande y hoy mismo por ejemplo probando estábamos hace un rato mirándolo y en un montón
de commodities también es decir con los parámetros que usamos en el nasdaq también en un montón de
commodities es decir al final claro que sí ese es el camino justamente para validar una estrategia
que opera poco otro sistema que tenemos así es iris también lo hemos comentado y lo hemos comentado
los directos os animo a seguir viendo los directos y por cierto esto es algo que lo he comentado en
el curso pero va a seguir vamos a seguir haciendo directos en principio todos los jueves por lo
tanto eso está abierto a todo el mundo pero también a un alumno quiero decir a mí si tú me vienes
en el chat hoy soy alumno del curso tengo esta duda me la pones y te contesto entonces aprovechar
eso y usarlo este es el objetivo de esas esas web es que hay veces que hay más gente veces que hay
más menos la mayoría de gente lo ve después pero yo sobre todo los hago no lo hago como una
de marketing supone eso es pequeño pero me gusta el hecho de tener un sitio donde todo el mundo
puede ir a hablar conmigo y vosotros podéis usarlo ahora cuando acabemos y ya no hagamos más clases
pues puedes oye esto no tengo voy a el jueves que sé que a las cinco de media está ser y le
preguntaré por tal perfecto lo por es que eres alumno y yo te contesto vale entonces ese es el
camino el camino es el que comenta raúl y hay que hacerlo así la manera de buscar la robusted el
objetivo es buscar la robusted es eso porque porque si un sistema en activos muy relativamente
distintos aguanta el tipo con las mismas configuraciones sin optimizarlo pues demuestra
que realmente hay ventaja y no es ese es el camino se podía dar por operable en un porfolio si luego
a ver en qué porfolio lo peras pero si la respuesta es sí a la uno en cuanto al rollo de los futuros
esto te he preparado un trabajito y en cuanto a los futuros lo cual sé que se ha explicado
simplemente podemos ver de manera práctica cómo cambiar de contra aquí ya te pones la venda
diciendo vale ya no me digas más ser si que lo has explicado lo sé sé que ya lo has explicado
pero ahora sí no lo entiendo bien bien planteado dice se ha hablado de cerrar el contrato anterior
y al ver posiciones del nuevo pero no está operando de momento se va a tener claro la
manera de ejecutar la operativa se trataría de parar la estrategia eliminar el símbolo
del momento que decidimos y añadir el símbolo al iniciar de nuevo es necesario cambiar la
configuración del algoritmo voy a tratar de ilustrarlo voy a tratar de ilustrarlo yo creo
aún así lo que lo que te voy a dar y creo que evidentemente va a salir para más más gente
aún así te voy a pedir que luego adiós a re veas la teoría de esto sobre todo la teoría
de veas la teoría porque porque al final a lo mejor ahora te va a quedar alguna cosa más más
clara mira este es el documento que nosotros cuando rolábamos futuros como sabéis actualmente lo
usábamos y ahora mismo lo he adaptado a un caso real de acuerdo que es el petróleo como vende
cada mes vende que además tiene entregable vale nos dos porque tenemos que hablar porque
se acaba el contrato espira entonces hay que cambiar el broker normalmente si hay entregable
como es el caso yo tengo aquí una ventana de transición que es el mes 80 y fante que me está
diciendo aquí me está diciendo las tres de y para el siguiente contrato es el jueves 20
las tres de y último día operable me dice julio 24 es el que tengo aquí la izquierda
esa es la información que a mí me resulta importante ya te avisa digo debido a la festividad
20 de julio 20 de julio es fiesta que es el 20 de julio estados unidos y no sé cuero
rol inmediatamente cuando te llega este mensaje de tres sesión ya puede rolar porque si no te
van a cerrar en seguramente menos de x horas o minutos ya deberías estar cerrado esto es lo
importante vamos a hay dos cosas en el rolo que la teoría os expliqué y traté de mostrarlo de
manera distinta pero entiendo que si no lo has hecho sea complicado tú tienes necesidad de
rolar pero una cosa es el sistema y otra cosa es la necesidad de rolar porque apenas porque
un discrecional igual es que si no le está operando hasta ayer o ayer antes ayer julio
y ahora pues tiene que pasarse a agosto porque aquí van mal corridos a mí este este mensaje me
ha avisado antes de ese me ha llegado otro antes de ese me ha llegado lo que pasa es que igual ya
no igual en este caso por la fiesta no no hay pero normalmente hay uno que te avisa de la fecha y
luego este del inmediato y ya es el inmediato y es cuidado y este lo envió el 13 es la fiesta
entonces ya digo cuando llega de media y vamos vamos mal pero los que hay los que no hay en los
que no hay vencimiento no te va a avisar los que no hay entregable perdón entregable no te va a
avisar por ejemplo ese pero se entrega y te avisa porque es muy grave y de hecho él te va a cerrar
pero cuidado que si no te cierran responsable eres tú te va a cerrar porque te va a cerrar
seguramente te va a multar te va a poner una sanción en la cuenta entonces tienes tú que
cerrar esta es la parte técnica como lo sabemos bueno nosotros todavía los tenemos todavía los
tenemos lo voy a enseñar todavía los tenemos en el calendario todavía los tenemos en el calendario
pero eso es un poquito saturado un poquito saturado ahora ya mañana no te enseño el
calendario en mi vida esta es la cita que yo tengo puesta tiene lugar el día 11
9 de cada mes y pongo ver notas en la en la del nombre arriba ya en el outlook se ve tengo
vencimiento mensual pero es mes corrido ejemplo en diciembre vence enero vence tres días laborables
antes de 25 cada contral tiene sus normas los hay que es el viernes de vencimiento los hay que
están este tiene esta que es caprichosa vence tres días laborables antes de 25 y rolamos tres días
laborables antes de vencimiento usualmente 17 es igual eso es una vez que yo tengo que me salta y
lo tengo para todos los futuros programado para que me siente bastantes días antes por si yo se
me olvida bien esto es la necesidad de rolar porque vence esto da igual si el sistema no es
sistema y tú tienes que rolar sí o sí haga lo que haga el sistema esté metido a lo que haga
bien dicho esto cuál es el momento óptimo del rolo o cuál es el momento óptimo de hacer el
continuo que es lo que sobre todo nos interesa esto porque yo tengo un continuo hecho que puedo
usar a roba cl pero puedo hacerlo yo recordáis que lo vimos vimos una práctica parece que
igual voy a tener que reiniciar el train session este os acordáis que os enseñé este ejercicio
era para ilustraros esto esto es el mismo futuro ls pero rolando siete días seis días cinco días
cuatro días antes a lo mejor ahí no lo veis bien pero yo os lo digo es arroba ese punto de igual
107 x 106 x 105 x 104 que se y esto cambia sólo el día que empalma el contrato entendéis no
tiene que ver con la operativa realidad esto es no tiene que ver con el día en que tú tienes que
arrolar tú tienes que arrolar pues antes de esa fecha que te he dicho dentro de lo óptimo cuando
puedas pero lo más cerca posible a lo óptimo simplemente porque tú si consideras que el óptimo
es el 107 lo ideal sería cambiar ese intervalo pero como os dije aquí en la teoría no obsesionaros
con eso porque sobre todo si es un futuro que tiene mucho volumen va a seguir haciendo volumen
un día antes entonces claro en los entregables sí que es muy peligroso y hay que ir con margen
y a veces se ha dado la paradoja que yo me ha obligado a arrolar el broker por esta vez
puede ser que sea así por la fiesta esta que dice antes de cuando es óptimo entonces yo me
tengo que buscar la vida es decir cómo me tengo que buscar la vida si yo aquí tengo esto yo al
final lo estaré corriendo imagínate que yo esto lo estoy operando en automático de acuerdo con
un sistema da igual en diario y por lo tengo yo tengo vamos a suponer arroba cl vale y yo
arroba cl sé que es lo tenía linkado en lo que no tiene razón pero es igual ahora lo vuelvo a abrir
lo vuelvo a abrir lo vuelvo a abrir porque si no es la estima porque estaba abierto y ya se veía
el teca teca aquí bueno es igual vale volvemos a reproducir lo que intentaba reproducir entonces
yo ahora aquí si tengo la rola cl el rola cuando sea vale pero ahora fíjate el número de contratos
que lleva lleva 350 que ya es el de la derecha te das lo llegáis a ver verdad ya es el de la
derecha decir ya está ya ha rolado ya ha rolado este contrato pero si yo necesito crear el mío
que lo solemos hacer acordaros que se puede hacer aquí a lo mejor si me ha obligado a
arrolar antes por lo que te decía pues yo me hago un custom aquí le puedo desplazar un día vale
operando marcando en el que estoy porque al final es toda la marca que ya está en agosto
tú ya deberías estar en julio porque ya lo hice aquí cuando cambia verde este indicador al final
lo que usamos esto es simplemente cuando está verde es que ya está el nuevo haciendo más
está configurado que ya ayer y ayer ya era aquí aquí empezaba el día 14 tal y al 15 abre el 17
el lunes el lunes ya abre haciendo más el nuevo ves aquí el verdadero el 17 ayer ayer ya abre el
viernes empieza carlos al cerca del cierre hay algunas velas de un minuto que está haciéndolo
al cierre diario no lo haría seguro y ya en la apertura del siguiente prácticamente todas un
minuto ya son con más volumen es decir ya el mercado ha cambiado esto para que lo uso para
ver qué está haciendo el mercado está haciendo la gente yo simplemente miro el volumen de cuyo
miro el volumen de n del siguiente del nuevo y voy comparándolos con una indicador que tengo y con
esa comparación pues lo me doy cuenta cuando el mercado empieza a considerarlo pero cuidado si
a mí el broker me que me hace rolar tengo que rolar vale si a mí el 13 me dice oye rola su
automóvil por culo yo rolo el 13 oye y otro varem ya seguir el sistema como pueda si no
podrá que al final cambiando lo que te digo puedes hacerlo vale porque esto si yo tengo aquí
y déjame mirar una cosa porque esto ahora se me ha ocurrido una manera enseñártelo porque me
acuerdo que tengo un petróleo aquí montado tengo un petróleo aquí montado tengo pero aquí
ves tengo 113 que exerce vez está ahora ya en el precio 80 37 y arriba es 81 vale si yo ahora
esto le voy modificando vale verás el precio que está ahora 80 vale en el momento en que yo vea
que el precio es 81 estará en el otro entiendes no sé vamos a poner 5 a no es al revés esto que
no haber rolado 102 es que ya ya está ya está casi acabado el 101 será igual 101 que exerce ahí está
es 101 que se re no ha rolado pero dejad el volumen como va queriendo es que están 81 el precio al
poner 100 101 ahora en este continuo no ha rolado pues haría eso si por lo que fuera me hubiera
habéis obligado raúl a arrolar pues me adaptaría el continuo que será el que operó este a uno que
estuviera todavía perdón al revés que no hubiera rolado que no hubiera rolado pero imagínate que
hubiera hecho lo contrario hubiera rolado antes entonces a lo mejor en vez de 103 tendría que
poner 104 porque he rolado antes pero si aún no he rolado por lo que sea y puedo hacerlo que eso
podrías hacer lo mejor en lsp porque me puede interesar en lsp bueno me puede interesar te lo
comete porque si yo sé que lsp cierra tiene un time de cerrar en tres días y otro que robar el
viernes pero sé sé que va a cerrar solo el lunes y sé que aún me quedan cuatro días más porque
rola siete antes que en el lsp en el nasdaq rola mucho antes vale pues a lo mejor lo dejo y que
cierre solo por tiempo el lunes me entiendes o qué que decir y puedo ahí cambiar la letra que
ahora yo pongo 102 y el precio es ya yo creo que ya va a cambiar no todavía en 102 está aún en el
103 acaba de cambiar porque 102 todavía estaba a cambiar esta noche el 103 ha cambiado la noche
pasada la noche del lunes al martes es uno tarde por lo que hemos visto el mercado ha hecho 104
el mercado hemos visto y esto 104 se tiene la idea entonces yo puedo confeccionar mi
continuo como quiera pero eso es el continuo que yo tengo que tiene que haber un óptimo que eso es
mirando cuál es el que tiene más volumen medio histórico vale lo vises a ver la teoría pero
insisto que hay dos cosas el óptimo y otra cuando tengo que hacerlo y si lo tengo que hacer lo tengo
que hacer sobre todo cuando hay entregable no hay debate ahí no hay debate así yo recibo un
aviso de tres sesiones en el rol inmediatamente tu rola rola porque digo nos están para tonterías
porque eso tiene entregable esto quedarse abierto es pupa y claro el vence el 20 vence él te está
diciendo que el last day es el 20 pero es festivo por lo tanto es de tal y por eso te está diciendo
que es antes es el 19 y como es pues seguramente cotizará esa mañana mañana cotizará pero ya
seguramente con un menor volumen decir aquí ahora estás viendo aquí el volumen del en un minuto de
este y el del otro y ya vas a ver que el de la izquierda ya está ajusteando mucho yo tengo aquí
la derecha tengo ves ciento de media o cientos contratos ya que tengo 21 esto ya está ya aquí
si ya tú no has rolado que te ve las ya de un minuto que ya no hacen los seis bien ya estás ahí
pidiendo la hora parte que estás jugando con fuego entonces espero que haya quedado claro esta idea
del rolo entre esto y volver ahora vuelve a ver la teoría de acuerdo vuelve a ver la teoría de
esta parte de futuros porque creo que yo creo que ahora sí que quedará más más claro vale en la
4 comentabas a la 3 la 3 decía sienes a cambiar la configuración de algoritmo genético en algún
caso no nosotros no lo tocamos el que el recomienda nuevamente lo dejamos solo lo único caso que lo
a veces lo tocamos es con el wall forward porque como no te deja aunque ahora tenemos un software
que os lo comenté aparte pero en el cual forma de transición está muy limitado por capacidad
por 32 bits esos problemas y él por defecto él te pone cien cien de población y y como se llama
población y no me sale eso a saldrá esas son cien cien vale que es tú le das a su jest y te sale
las dos vale pero si tú lo ponemos fuera te las deja tocar nosotros antes de marcar wall
forward lo hacemos y depende cuánta nos sale lo tocamos o no entonces lo tocamos pero ahí sí que
a lo mejor de manera que sale pues lo tocas tú porque más o menos es múltiplo que cinco veces
algo así lo tocamos para para que salgan menos porque si no el archivo es muy grande y no va
al principio no principio no en principio en principio no vale y la 4 hablaba del máximo
adverso es cursión decía si para colocarle esto sale a comprobar saltaría un estómago en velas
de un minuto en un data 2 para colocarlo correctamente podríamos verlo de manera práctica
esto entiendo que te te a ver lo estoy leyendo rápido porque eso está aquí en las preguntas
de raúl pues las botas se ha soltado se ha soltado unas cuantas y el día antes el día antes a las
cuatro a la tarde y bueno para comprobar en data 2 esto lo que quería decir era un poco esto que
esto lo ves un poco en el list es decir tú es lo mismo que eso mismo que porque en el list
salta un estómago decir si tú aquí añades una chímbol le añades también apple vale en un
minuto bajo vale yo tengo apel aquí debajo tengo arriba el diario y se alinea a cierre
cierre y hasta yo corre el sistema en el data 1 arriba y abajo no es claro yo aquí esto aquí
tienes un solo 5 minutos entonces yo tengo aquí arriba el sistema y eso es lo mismo por el que
pasa esto es lo mismo motivo pero para que lo entiendas lo mismo que pasa y os enseguire lo
el lift vale y ahora aquí tengo el sistema que resulta que es la polla de vinagre vale y
porque acordaros que cualquier vela que no sea la actual es decir la que está operando ahora
y desde que abro desde ese momento en que estoy abriendo la operativa no me la ejecuta en tiempo
real las resas son históricas entonces las reglas de que toca que precio que orden se ejecuta antes
es una suposición él no lo sabe esto de abajo es lo que hace el lift vale esto de abajo es lo que
hace el lift entonces si tú quieres ver si un ardenche en un minuto se ejecutaría me refería
a esto a lo mejor lo ligue con la máxima pecha excursión pero me refería a esto si tú tienes
que saber si recuota de verdad o no y ahora aquí tengo el performance report y ahora aquí le voy
a activar el lift en un minuto y resulta que va a pasar a hacer 84 para dinero pero a veces
he visto casos y puede pasar vamos a ver si con aún un ver más bajo pasa el lift se lo traga y
aquí ya empieza a ser positivo no se lo traga del todo vamos a ver si con 005 si no voy a poner
en cinco minutos para que me entiendas porque hay casos vivi un caso de hecho una que pasa
porque no sé qué ha pasado ahora tiene operaciones ahí esta vez aquí con el lift se nos está tragando
con el lift se nos está tragando es decir ahora aquí yo ahora tendría este sistema esto ya digo
tú una práctica voy a para que lo veáis ahora aquí le quito el lift va a ganar mucho va a ganar
mucho 4 64 era un susto ahí pero bueno podría ser en algunos casos que ni lo tuviera eso pero
no sé por lo que se lo tiene le activo el lift y bueno va a activar el lift y ya está y sigo viendo que
tiene una curva bastante alta que hay sus mechas que ya denotan que hay trampa que sólo se ven así
pero esto porque es esto es por un problema de que está saltando en un minuto es decir esto es lo que
yo te quería decir es decir tú tienes que ver en un minuto si yo le he puesto un stop de 005 al
final el lift que hace él va a pasar el backtest teniendo en cuenta el histórico de abajo el de
un minuto pero es la misma regla es decir en la de un minuto que va a hacer sólo sabe acordaros
los cuatro campos del precio open high low y close sabe sus precios no sabe cómo se recorrió la de
un minuto tampoco ahora sí sabe cómo se recorrió la diaria pero lo sabe en gran unometría de un
minuto no lo sabe menos como no sabría menos tic a tic vale si ahora te lo te lo pondré tic a tic
en seis meses verás cómo como la cosa ya se equivoca bueno pero vamos a hacer ya a no es que
están seis meses perfecto perfecto para no saber qué quiere decir que estos tres siguen siendo
falsos esos seis que ves siguen siendo falsos porque el rango de 005 es menor que el de un
minuto y por lo tanto le cuesta mucho moverse así por lo tanto salta en falso igualmente me
explicó que tú tienes que ver que aquí el rango es de 1,2 hay que ver cuál es el rango medio y
ver si te está pasando la manera más sencilla de hacerlo o demás es lo que te digo carga seis
meses aunque sea poco straight y en esos seis meses mira si ponerlo tic a tic cambia y ahora
aquí tengo performance report que es la leche vale ahora le voy a poner el me va a tardar un poco
pero lo vamos a hacer y vamos a tener paciencia porque me va a tener que bajar seis meses apple
en tic a tic lo vamos a dejar ahí trabajando vale a dejar porque va a tardar mogollón vale y seguimos
con las preguntas vale sólo dejo y luego verás cómo eso ahora se ha roto porque ahora sí que
lo he verificado el problema es que tic a tic no puedo hacerlo mucho más atrás no pero si es
así que debería tener vale 5 qué opinión tenéis de programar nuestra tic para aprovechar
las grandes probabilidades las small caps podíamos ver algo de cómo hacer ponse más
sección en las acciones a operar durante la sesión según por ejemplo su valor capital flotchi bueno
súper breve raúl esto te voy a pedir otra vez lo mismo que se pidió con maestro esto lo que lo
va a hacer escáner para filtrar escáner escáner es esto yo te lo voy a enseñar aquí muy breve
pero te pido que veas un vídeo tú puedes tener aquí acciones hemos puesto algunas para ver y
claro que sí cualquier aquí cualquier sistema no sé de qué sistema ha puesto de alberto pero
si es mínimamente tenencial debería ir bien de coña de coña a ver que este mandamos aquí puesto
a ruptura de acciones a pero está en diario no no no no no no no no es posible no no crea
esto vamos a ponerlo en 15 minutos no sé si las reglas permiten eso no le vamos a poner
tres meses a cualquier sistema de ruptura mínimamente que se adapte habría que ver
tal que tenga esto debería de irte bien debería irte bien en un sistema en un activo mega volátil
como como estos vale aquí ya te gana es cual son dos operaciones da igual da igual es simplemente
un ejemplo para que lo veáis vale puede que no vaya en todas este y habría que mirarlo y demás
pero de verdad que son buenos que eso tiene un entre el lingo un poco un poco holgado no
esto está atado a diario y habría que adaptarle listo por ser algo más más cercano entiendo
habría que adaptarle esto como era esto esto pero no es eso es un 0 2 por ciento para 0 2
será para diario y además solo va largo eso va bien de meter este activo debería haber ido corto
habría venido entonces sí que puedes pero teniendo en cuenta las reglas del juego vale las reglas
de juego con van a ser van a ser acciones que deberás ir largo porque por eso por dejar tu
borro esta hb que hace que son difíciles todas estas acciones van a ser har tu borro vale por lo
tanto olvídate de ir de ir corto con ellas vale vas a tener que ir largo y claro que puedes
claro que puedes el problema es que en la metodología que usan los pescadores los day traders
que esto es típico operativa de traders ellos buscan acciones la peran y esto es complicado
de implementar un sistema tú lo que sí que puedes hacer es una lista ejecutar la cada día y ir ahí
distinto y a partir de ahí en esa acción pasar el sistema antes previamente un sistema como
decíamos que vaya en muchas lo preparas para hacer una cesta de bastantes acciones y que sea
flexible y a partir de ahí lo lo pones a operar en las acciones que te diga cada día que lo normal
esta la manera que trabajamos es tú lo sacas de una lista de éstas como haces esto un scan
tienes aquí un scan vamos a son más o menos le puedes poner un folder y aquí tú creas que
símbolos usar vale puedes puedes aquí meter todas incluyendo te c puedes buscar tres y son
símbolos que la verdad no lo tengo muy mirado y no sé si hay algún índice específico de eso
no sé sinceramente habría que mirarlo no sé si no pues la desamanija pero aquí le pones todas
incluyendo te c le dices cuál es que lo ir vale y aquí por ejemplo un criterio típico pues yo que
sé sería volumen volumen medio de cinco días que sea menor que cuánto cuánto hace esto de volumen
alberto no sé no sé yo que sé cuántas acciones hacen esto no perdona mejor market cap no quizá
las de market cap donde estaban a ver que me acuerde aquí hay un montón esto no lo usamos
ahora mismo pero ahí hay los de market cap también en market cap no no es aquí los de market cap
estará capitalización aquí margen capitalización yo sé que capitaliza esto alberto lo sabes 5
millones no sé a ver si hay algo que capitaliza si hay algo vale hay muchas hay muchas vale
entonces a partir de ahí te puedes crear otras reglas tú esto ahora yo puedes hacer que se
configure y me lo he saltado pero una de las opciones que tienes es que tienes es programarlo
automáticamente que los resultados los guarde que los resultados los guarde en una custom
un símbolo list que luego podrás abrir en un radar screen que te lo notifique por email entiendes
decir puedes hacer un montón de cosas de este tipo entonces tú puedes crear un símbolo nivel
puedes poner aquí infinitos criterios hasta puedes poner un easy language pero es mejor o sea si tú
usas un indicador se ejecuta el local es mucho más lento todo lo que uses de que ya tenga él que
tiene como ves mil cosas ya va vía automática en el servidor y va bastante más rápido entonces
de precio que este era un precio mayor que tal esto normalmente la mayoría se hace hasta lo
contrario es decir este que nos tiene hecho se ve es que te ponen descripción para que salga que
el cierre esté entre 10 y 100 pues lo mismo al revés que el cierre sea menor de 5 porque yo quiero
solo acciones pequeñas vale que el volumen de sea mayor postú menor el market cap sea entonces
al final pues hacer un poco es todo lo contrario a las mayorías que hay sabes porque tiene aquí
algunos de ejemplo que no me acuerdo dónde estaban los ejemplos sample scans vale era que algunos
de este ejemplo los puedes abrir ves algunos técnicos de crecimiento program value technical
vale y vale pues pues pues por ser cualquiera de estas a cualquiera de estas pero que normalmente
normalmente ya te digo las que te las que te filtra las que te filtra pues es al revés el telas el
telas filtra por los que tienes contrario a este le hago le puedo hacer un guardar como no creo
a ver copi scan hasta escan venga he hecho muy movers de unos así no me ha sacado el otro y aquí
lo que te digo lo haces esto lo contrario el cierre menor que 5 o 10 saber 5 no sé no tengo
experiencia en este tipo de volumen que esté haciendo volumen eso sé que me interesa pero no
sé si esto es mucho poco lo dejamos market cap al revés menor a 100 me pilla puesto 5 años
pero vamos un millón de free flow venga y hasta que hayan subido que no sé qué que tengan un
cambio tal no sé esto lo dejado que son acciones que realmente se están moviendo pero de las
pequeñas vamos a ver si esto ahora está algo no no van a dar el puesto cosas absurdas porque
no hay ninguna que cumpla todo este todo este criterio mejor es demasiado exigentes todo el
volumen no sé si esto sigue teniendo sentido sigue siendo muy poco pero bueno es el camino
mejor aquí el cambio es demasiado exigente siempre aquí un poco
a mí me interesa quiero que se muevan fuerte
no me interesa que se hayan movido tanto no por el último día más de un 5% ya me vale
5 días no vamos a ver si este de algo pero así cada una pero bueno tienes un poco la idea
ya la sección se la conecto aquí con esto pues la puedo abrir y está a porque le he puesto
color perfecto
tampoco se está a porque es la global global y saque la posibilidad perfecto
lo que hacemos es esa asociación no sé no sé si eso no yo no sigo pero entiendes
es la manera de buscarlas la manera de buscarlas es esta para la manera de buscarlas es esta eso
es una escala vale tú le configuras a bueno es que seguramente aquí en el universo estoy pensando
que ya el universo habrá excluido o te ces tienes que decirle incluir o te ces y hasta la gente
las quiero pedar pero aquí fíjate ya han salido 37 acciones que cumplen ese criterio que tienen
menor market cap que tal y tal y pues bueno no sé alguno de vosotros conocéis estas acciones pues ahí
entonces sé que me da el valor de los indicadores ves que está bueno he dejado este 5 días
se han movido un 60 por ciento seguramente es una acción de este tipo es ahí pues está largo es
lo que te decía es decir al final el problema es que no tiene bien adaptada la salida pero este
tipo de acciones de verdad no es que es igual es como el bitcoin tú le pones cualquier cosa que
siga tendencia y que luego salga con el método y el margen es tan amplio que va a ganar no hace
falta ni que lo trabajes demasiado pero claro necesitas buscar cosas de este tipo es una locura
que ha subido en cinco días se ha multiplicado está ha comprado aquí en 15 entonces esa es un
poco la idea pero ha comprado 16 y hasta 24 eso es un poco la idea pero temas que ya digo no está
dimensionado bien para no está dimensionado bien para para y traía pues ha pensado para tal y
entonces el stop es demasiado elevado a lo mejor de 0 0 5 y el canal de vídeo está bien un poco
mejor ahora aquí ya saldrá vez haya salido antes es salido a lo mejor es demasiado poco se sale
demasiado pronto hay que verlo es un poco ajustarlo a este tipo de acciones seguramente
hace falta ajustarlo por volatilidad y hasta y ese es un poco el tema si está esto te va a dejar
dentro te va a dejar dentro en la mayoría de veces claro que va a fallar pero te va a dejar
dentro pero insisto solo largo mucho cuidado mucho cuidado la exposición riesgos gigantesco
porque la volatilidad te puede matar aquí aquí esta acción que locura porque eso parece que los
rangos gigantesco de si ahí toca eso en el mismo día toca 34 y 12 el mismo día el mismo día en
una hora se divide por tres la acción 300 90% 60% entonces claro pero sí sí pero pero este
tipo de acciones con sistemas se pueden trabajar no sé si está dimensionada bien si las comisiones
están bien o se nada y digo que esto habría que mirarlo todo no sé no sé porque a bueno porque
se ha enganchado ahí ha perdido la antemenada y no el problema es eso que tienes que aquí es que
ser acciones están muertas hasta que no lo están y y por lo tanto operar un sistema permanente ahí
como lo hacen ellos habría que hacer lo distinto como lo hacen ellos no sirve no sirve ahora puedes
buscar un término medio es decir a lo mejor buscar medium cap seguramente no son tan volátiles pero
son más que las otras que buscan un término medio pero en las que usan los day traders es muy
complicado porque esa acción se ha podido pasar meses plana ahí es muy complicado tienes que
filtrarlo y cuando despierta que despierte pero si puedes intentar si quieres probarlo lo que te
digo en tu buscador y aplicando el sistema cada día cambiado sería un poco el camino vale es
autónomo para gestionar capital no espérate algo volumen rango vale bien 6 pueden ser efectivos
de un fimo natch en un sistema no sé no creo pero bueno sí o sea bueno al final fimo natch
50 por ciento 33 por ciento es igual un tercio si el final es muy parecido a esas cantidades un
tercio la mitad es parecido el número exacto al final es uno de menos seguramente voy a analizar
podríamos no complementarlo eso es programación y es probablemente avanzada se puede implementar
en código sí claro que se puede tampoco es extremadamente complicado pero no lo vamos a
hacer en directo es programación programación y si se puede claro que se puede pero tienes
que computar piensa que tienes que ir guardando los mínimos los máximos puedes hacerlo con alguna
función que se va a probarlo tienes que ir guardando el mínimo el máximo y entonces
calcular cuando hay un mínimo en qué momento ese mínimo es relevante o sea todo ese tipo
de cosas y contemplarlas no es fácil pero si se puede 7 es necesario ser autónomo para gestionar
capital en alguno es verdad podríamos ver algún consejo de fiscalidad tan agonímico tanto en el
caso que sino capital como para una cuenta particular pues no no puedo no podemos ver
nada referente a fiscalidad lo único que le puede decir porque esto ya está hablado por mil
preguntas al respecto de otra gente que yo te puedo poner en contacto direct directo con
john porcar le puedes decir que vas de parte nuestra y te atenderá mal pero aún así ya digo
son temas fiscales que la ley es muy puñetera y no te deja decir cosas este tipo entonces a ver
en principio para ti no hace falta no hace falta ahora para gestionar capital de terceros en algún
ex bueno pues hay que ver al final es una actividad económica y entiendo que depende y lo que depende
pero ya digo yo no te puedo dar más datos primero no lo sé en detalle nosotros somos una SL y por
supuesto tributamos de todo de todo lo que ganamos tristemente acabo de hacer mi renta
justamente esta semana la particular la empresa de sociedades y va después y hay que pagar eso
está claro pero pero vaya ya te digo lo máximo que te puedo decir es eso no te puedo no te puedo
ayudar mucho más pero evidentemente lo que sé que te digo que cualquier operativa en bolsa al final
no deja de ser un un arrendamiento o bien o bien el rendimiento de la actividad económica o bien
una incremento de incremento patrimonial como cualquier inversión términos generales esto no
es que aplique a esto no es una en términos generales en términos generales
pero ya digo si quieres me lo preguntas por el disco lo que sea nos llamas y yo te pongo
contacto directo con él y saldremos nuestro y tal seguro que atenderá como siempre hace
pues muy amablemente vale seguimos con las de juan manuel 816 no vamos a hacer descanso
si mi garganta lo acepta seguimos a manuel que ya si raúl ayer había ya forzado juan manuel
ha visto digo yo las veo raúl y voy con mis preguntas a las 12 y 58 de la noche
y ya hoy durante el día de hoy no ha habido ninguno más así que ha sido ha sido el último
jamón se lleva el premio de la última pregunta durante el curso está por que luego seguiremos
respondiendo que nadie sufra que seguiremos respondiendo pero evidentemente ya no en directo
ya no en directo por eso dimos este mes a mí ya la verdad hay bastantes preguntas pero esperaba
más preguntas no sé si eso es muy bueno muy malo entiendo que es bueno pero pero ahí esperaba
más más preguntas pero luego seguiremos respondiendo pero lógicamente no es lo mismo
no es lo mismo como os decía lo más parecido será al dir los directos de acuerdo ahí queréis
oír mi atracción pelada voz y ver mi bella cara vale eso de veces de ver los jueves a las 5 y
media en tu entusiasmo para manuel deja aquí sus dudas en fase preliminar si tenemos varias
salidas para nuestro sistema que nos gustan por ejemplo por tiempo otra por señal contraria y
dólar recomendar es utilizar las es para elegir una o probarías manualmente cada una de ellas
para ver su comportamiento y elegir la más adecuada a ver no solo puedes sino que muchas
veces debes tener varias es decir no hay ningún problema en termas de salidas no hay ningún
problema tener varias salidas depende del tipo de sistema claro porque si hablamos de optimizar y
demás ahí sí que la cosa pues se puede ir complicando que a los de libertad muestra sentido
entonces tal lo que sí que no solaparía es decir tú me estás hablando de un tiempo bien señal
contraria bien tp bien en ningún problema un problema vale ningún problema ver optimizar la
de señal ya va optimizada con el sistema es entiendo que sí y el tp el tiempo pues puedes
utilizar las barras nuevamente pues así que puedes utilizar los principios sí puedes pero
poco y depende poco y depende no no abusaría en exceso de ello no usar el exceso y luego
muy importante el tema de los incrementos no vimos mucho tanto la teoría como la práctica
los excel y demás de hecho vimos que nosotros en apolo hicimos hasta un cambio de eso en relación
a sus temas tiene múltiples salidas o sólo simple bueno sé no sé qué importancia tiene
esto como el porque o sea simplemente te lo digo porque sea como sea puede cambiar mañana
nosotros en ser san hoy en día en ese gregado como sabes por motivos diversos
tenemos menos sistemas operando los que quisiéramos pero por ejemplo apolo tiene dos salidas no tiene
tres salidas realidad tp stop y contraria y nemesis tiene una salida entiendes arte misa que
aún mismo no opera pero espero poderlo hacer operar pronto porque ahora lo que haremos seguramente por
eso meter a la cuenta nos hace perder es bastante más dinero y entonces meter a meter a mejorar un
par de artemisas y veremos veremos a ver cómo cómo lo podemos hacer y probablemente porque ya nos
han dicho que podemos ir a futuros en cero pues veremos a ver en cero si podemos ir montando
esa carterita de futuros pero bueno veremos a qué más que más hay que es mejor no no no sé mejor
la simplicidad siempre es buena pero tener dos salidas no tiene por qué ser contrario
lo simple entiendes decir finales lo que necesito es el sistema no debe tener demasiados grados de
libertad pero tampoco demasiado pocos pues no no le permites que capte la señal siempre señales
ruido esto creo que la teoría se habló bastante de ello se habló bastante de ello entonces ambas
cosas son más cosas son varias más cosas son varias como siempre depende del tipo de sistema y
y ya digo la optimización depende de lo que lo conozca se pide que ya lo es operado en la
nosotros en apolo tenemos una gran ventaja con con nasdaq que es que lo llevamos operando muchísimos
años se habéis fijado en el fondo que estaba y estaba en operaba en las carteras antes de venir
a dar con ex y cuantos años puede de la polo alberto 11 años que lleva 11 años operando
operando futuros es claro al final ya le tiene sensibilidad te da más margen ahora sí te puedes
equivocar pero tienes más sensibilidad sistema ambas cosas pueden pero sin dudas simple sin dudas
menos quiz quiz y menos siempre es más pero no llevemos al extremo eso porque al final
caos y no menos es más es no pero tiene que hacer falta captar la señal leyendo una respuesta
rubén sobre igual forward remase el tema y vi que se vio en una práctica por encima en caso de que
se diera tiempo se fuera posibilidad de hacer un ejemplo el formante ese práctico va a ser
complicado no va a ser posible no va a ser posible lo que te recomiendo es lo que te os he dicho
antes ver el ver el webinar ver el vídeo en ese vídeo que os enseñaba antes de la web nuestra
hay hay bastante tema tratado del world forward y y lo que vimos tanto en la teoría como en la
práctica pues te puede servir te puede te puede te puede servir al final es que es lo que os digo
el hecho de usarte de ese sonó es plataforma entonces he explicado el concepto y cómo va todo
lo de lo de lo de un world forward yo creo que estaba muy claro como va entendido por todo el
mundo y demás ahora la mecánica de tres es cada uno pues tiene sus cosas ya está pero esos
tienes tienes ya digo tienes vídeos de tres se son ya es material los vídeos que veas de
world forward antiguos de tres es eso ya te digo sin ningún problema están totalmente vigor porque
ha cambiado cero coma así que puedes usar esos esos vídeos en cuanto a por folios sería interesante
poner ejemplos según porcentaje de cartera y cómo se progresaría por ejemplo idea por folio inicial
10.000 cuántos sistemas tipo de sistema mercados para ajustarse a la cuenta una vez que se avanza
tiene mayor capital 20.000 por folio que cambios haría respecto al anterior añadir contados en
mercados cuales así como guía general hasta como formar un porfolio de 100.000 bueno yo creo que
esto lo he respondido antes bastante porque ya había introducido el tema en compañero el compañero
bisector y yo creo que ha estado bastante respondido creo que ha estado bastante respondido no sé si
estás en el directo y puedes afirmar o negar si esto ha quedado bastante respondido diría que
no está verdad Juan Manuel no veo ningún Juan Manuel como tal ve un par de juanes pero si es
Juan Manuel entiendo que no está entonces yo diría que está ya que está de menos que anhelar eso
que te digo cuando sistemas tipo de sistemas es que esto la respuesta no está no no los sistemas
no es una no es una frutería que vas y los compras entonces al final es depende de los que tengas
si tú tienes más es mejor también pero más que estén bien que sean buenos decir si tú puedes y
te caben más no te caben pues tengo que elegir es que no hay más lo ideal al menos es tener tres
ahora puede ser no puede ser oye pues dos oye sólo puede ser uno pues uno es que no no hay no hay
no hay una respuesta mágica esto que quiere danales capital y tiene sistemas más sistemas
siempre siempre más sistemas hay en mercados cuales bueno esto sí que ya os di en el se hablaba
bastante he hablado hoy y hablé os puse este ejemplo de commodities hemos visto mi ejemplo
decir acciones tienes ahí mini nasdaq mini sb mini rasell puedes tocar el boom puedes tocar
dax mini dax microlásina volumen aceptable hay que mirarlo bien pero el principio si esto en cuanto
equity algo de bonos y en commodities por supuesto oro petróleo si puedes gasolina y a partir de ahí
te da un poco esta referencia antes de para que veas esto para que veas esto de las de las
los futuros por tipos de futuros ya os di una referencia también en porfolio de commodities los
que pone son perfectamente válidos pero mirar algunos por volumen también y a partir de ahí
en todo lo que puedas es que en todo lo que puedas y te permitas que no hay mucha historia es probar
que si tú tienes el tema es probar a ver los que me caben por garantías porque es que es eso voy
a probar cómo van mis sistemas ahí que no es el tema es buscar entre lo que tengo y lo que puedo
no no no se ve nada que yo te diga tienes que operar el futuro del uranio tú tienes un sistema
que vaya y puedes pagar las garantías es que no se entiendes no es eso los futuros más usados
y más típicos evidentemente equity evidentemente oro evidentemente petróleo la también se opere el
gas natural muchos momentos ha ido bien la gasolina suele de muy bien el gasol de cada función también
energía y eso no te puedo decir y en las en la software ni bien pero pican de garantías y tiene
un volumen a decir usted entonces ya está la soja por ejemplo la soja va bien sus variantes
tampoco va mal la aceite soja la soja comercial maíz trigo si hay es que ya digo es es probarlo
es decir no sirve tú tienes programado no sé un sistema minerva bueno pues los vas a ver entre
los que puedes operar oye tengo minerva en tal de momento lo tengo si además tienes minerva
saturno neptuno y la galaxia andrómeda pues pues entonces oye te felicito y en los que lo hayas
enseñado en los que pruebes y puedas ir pues adelante pero el camino inicial es más mercados
bueno pues a ver si minerva va en la soja a ver si minerva va en el micro que hemos visto antes
petróleo a ver si minerva va en el micro no sé qué porque estamos dando una cuenta pequeña entonces
hay apartes de lo que puedes entonces hay que seguir viendo lo que puedes y lo que y lo que no
como se ha enseñado antes un poco en el excel y jugando y viendo el excel y sea poder mirar maestro
que me eso me dice la exposición nosotros no enseñé la última clase las cosas que más nos
gusta de maestro entonces bueno un poco esas un poco las pautas que te puedo dar a este a este
respecto vale no sé si él no está pero sí general los que estáis podéis antes igual que yo
creo que si está esto satisfactoriamente respondido lo que sería la pregunta cuatro
pues os lo agradecería yo digo que sí lo que está asumiendo que os voy a enviar todo el excel y esto
5 en cuanto a ser copiado a estarás evitado puñetero estarás evitado éstas evitado esta
como no las ha evitado las cinco no la tengo en el word las tengo aparte para así tener bien
repartido el material sobre el precio de incubación recomiendas como life o la es como mínimo capital
life o life con mínimo capital cuántos meses sería ideal tener un sistema de incubación en
cuanto sería el mínimo de meses aceptable hay algún caso donde se permita pasar a live cuenta
real sin pasar por incubación cómo comparar los resultados del periodo de incubación con los
debates para decidir si cumple requisitos para operar live y que nos debemos fijar curva de la
esa me gusta a ver te doy cuenta que la tengo que improvisar pero no pasa nada improvisamos
recomiendas demo live o live con mínimo capital a ver si tú estás empezando y no tienes experiencia
sobre sistema estamos dando un sistema nuevo de cero vale que no ha operado antes y tú no tienes
ya una cartera gran operando y yo sí recomiendo incubación pequeña o sea incubación pequeña no
sé darte un tiempo con manuel porque no es lo mismo se va que van 5 minutos o 15 o en 30 que
va en diario o que va en semanal vale pero ya respondiendo a la siguiente pregunta no es
una barbaridad ir a live directo para nada pero depende de un par de cosas una tu experiencia
bueno tres tu experiencia previa es decir cuántas veces has llevado sistemas a la es decir como
cuánto te has demostrado a ti mismo que tu criterio para crear sistemas y evaluarlo es
bueno para tener la confianza de llevarlo al mercado directo vale y otra sería si ya tienes
cartera si ya tienes cartera si tú ya tienes cartera puedes meter a lo mejor un live de hecho
hay hay traders que lo que tienen es una cartera secundaria haciéndolo por ejemplo para eso hoy
hay colegas que lo están haciendo nosotros ahora probablemente lo haremos cuando vamos a uno nuevo
es decir tú metes tu cartera normal en alguna es normal y tienes cero para hacer eso metes cero
aprobarlo pero aparte de eso vamos a suponer que sea futuros que no sea alguna ex podrías meterlo
a operar con muy poco capital el problema es que estamos hablando de una cuenta pequeña con poco
capital pues a lo mejor no va a ser posible que no va a haber el futuro que menos vas a poder operar
como hemos visto en el ejemplo la cartera de 25 que podía ir con 10 ya lo has visto con 10.000 ya
va a ser el peso un contrato va a ser el peso que le vas a poner no vas a poder operar la con medio
contrato entonces realmente pero bueno si podrías a lo mejor meterlo en un cfd y después te queda
hacer incubación por fuerza te quedas en incubación en ese caso por fuerza cuánto tiempo el mínimo
posible hay autores que dicen tres meses seis meses a mí todo esto hasta y gente que dice un año
me parece gratuito es depende es en un sistema que operaría como compararías métricas bueno
pues lo mismo que la supervisión la supervisión al final que va manteniendo los parámetros
evidentemente la curva pero la curva cuidado que es muy engañosa porque no tiene nada que ver una
curva de un mes con la curva de de un de un año y mira ligado con esto espérate que me acuerdo
de apple porque mejor puedo aprovechar eso para enseñarte un poco esto queríamos antes por aquí
cargando a apple vale y quiero pensar pero habrá que hacerle así que ya ha bajado los tics está
calculando porque lógicamente ahora está procesándolo en tic entonces también le va a
le va a costar un poco pero bueno respondiendo un poco a lo que a lo que decíamos ya lo ha procesado
ahora tenemos 136 bueno aún aún se ha aguantado en un tic 6 meses y esto sí que es real pero si
tengo activado el live ahora solo poso seis veces tiene un tic un tic y un tic esto sí que es real
eso sí que es real porque en un tic sabe perfectamente cómo tuvieron en lugar los
pedidos esto es lo único real 100% esto sabe es evidentemente cómo se ejecuta y cómo salta
pero gente que salta en directos que se trata es un esto tan cercano que salta directo aquí el
sé que es real bueno sí sé que es real pero hace un montón de operaciones pero son 42 no son
tantos pero fíjate lo que gana nada más que le meta un tic más tengo uno por contrato y uno
desnivel de cómo le venga como como me ponga dos rompo bueno ya está roto pero cada cálculo
que la cuesta porque están un tic es ya está ya a cero cuando solo por un tic más que es mucho
los tics pero es muy sensible es decir realmente esto ahora mismo aunque tenga yo seis meses yo
ahora te quito te quito vamos a hacer dos cosas pasar el lift otra vez a un minuto para que veamos
aunque sea dos dos tics fíjate cómo se ha como se ha quedado la curva eso es importante me acuerdo
quién hablaba de esto no sé lo que el jate el lift en un minuto ahí lo tienes entonces la única
manera está seguro es esto que tu sistema sea de más tiempo porque si le afecta a esto es que es
de corto plano seguramente lo tienes que cargarle seis meses y ver si ese mes es idéntico tiene que
ser idéntico no cambiaron nada si cambia algo quiere decir que está está tocado entonces esté
hasta en un minuto es mentira vale y ahora le quito el lift y la mejor o peor pero irá bien de locos
mucho más y es mentira lo que veis antes es mentira la que le pongo un tic jate que ahora le
he puesto dos tics de coste vale con dos y de coste aún así aquí no tiene ningún problema y
con el otro pues se rompe vale es decir no tiene no tiene ningún ningún sentido vale este es el
ejemplo lo que decía tienes que ver que en un minuto la orden se mantenga bien porque si no
aquí fíjate hace un trade que es alucinante pero como ejecuta el trailing está tan pegado
le salta antes en realidad lo que él cree porque él no se ha dado cuenta que ha vuelto el precio
ahí o sea él él no se ha dado cuenta que esto ha hecho él se cree que compra aquí la apertura no
más o menos lo que veo compra en la apertura y vendía 220 se queda la verdad hecho compra aquí
pero no le salta esto cuando se le salta entiendes entonces el final bueno no me
fijaba si le salta pero entiendo que sí que debe saltar no tenía alguna pregunta por aquí dos
marcados tengo nada no me lo has marcado bueno esto de josé de solo hay algo más arriba vale
como se quita la baldera lo puedes pegar por juan molillo buenas que software alternativo para
world for world podías recomendar merece la pena a ver yo creo que puedes manejarte ahora si no hay
problemas económicos y demás este por lo que hemos visto de momento no parece ir mal pero bueno
todavía lo hemos comprado regular todavía tengo responsabilidades por mi parte pero
no sé si hemos comprado 500 dólares hemos comprado y bueno ya digo se puede
el de tres sesión puedes usarlo tienes un limitación ahora que tiene el matriz ya si
tienes los dos yo los trabajaría bien los dos los conocería bien entonces vas viendo aquí tienes
esa información y lo puedes lo puedes ver ya digo hacer o no sé nada sé que lo he comprado y lo
hemos probado un par de veces de momento y a falta de hacer alguna prueba un poco más profunda y está
bien a veces aquí entra y salta directo a ver cómo ha cambiado el lito un tick no es que no tiene
nada nada que ver entonces esto me ligaba con la pregunta última así lo de no es solo lo de
apple que ya está resuelto pero ligaba con lo que como comparar los resultados le bates no sé
por qué pensaba que eso me iría bien que los hemos fijado vale si si era por esto bueno al final
es lo que te digo el problema que tienes ahora de fijar mínimo tienes las 30 operaciones es un
problema que al final por las métricas de manera hechas de manera todas las maneras que
os he explicado técnicas suelen ser más lentas que mirar la curva pero la curva es lo que te digo
cambia mucho si tú miras una curva de corto plazo a ver vamos a ahora está con él está con el
tick no vale mira déjame ahora para a ver si me sirve esto te voy a quitar las comisiones más que
nada para ver si al menos me deja una curva medio medio decente para bueno que no será medio decente
pero será una curva positiva le para enseñarte lo que lo que voy y no al final es un efecto del
auto de la autoscala como siempre decimos en la autoscala tú los gráficos autoscalan tienes
este este problema que sin comisiones hasta con el tick fíjate que es la hostia pues está muy bien
está muy bien han le quitado las comisiones y ahora sigan a cabo es gratis operar ese tipo
esto mucha gente cae cuando empieza que pasada pero es gratis por eso por ejemplo los los
market makers lo tienen fácil porque si tú realmente te cuesta gratis real es bastante
fácil o es mucho más fácil porque gratis el todo no hay un slip es un spread aquí no hay
nada no hay contar el spread o contar a los simplemente estoy comprando y vendiendo contra
la casa tocando para el spread todos los ratos de haciendo trades de súper poco dinero de beneficio
es el otro lado de los otros es haciendo eso es irreal tienes ustedes realmente no los podría
hacer así nunca bueno alguno pero no es realista esto pero efectos de lo que te quiero decir es
decir para que entendamos imaginamos que eso es algo histórico de años no es el caso pero es
igual yo tengo bueno aquí ya se va a tomar viento todo eso vamos a suponer esto será la realidad
vale y entonces yo ahora te cargo aquí cinco días es el mismo sistema con lo cual deberías ver algo
parecido a esto no no hay tres bueno vamos a meter 10 seguimos entre ir a buenos que arriba
un diario que no me supongo que se que ya habrá ya habrá algo a ver
como puede ser que es que es el día de este operando en diario no puede que así no sé
cuándo tengo de max bar a ver tampoco son más valioso comentando 50 a esto tengo que meterle
pues 40 es que antes tenía seis tres meses y una gran falta igual a los que pasa de los seis meses
se pasa tres con el libro había caído con el max bar es un poco la efectiva se me sale
porque los improvisando el problema que tienen las preguntas últimas chicos que no me las puedo
preparar pues pues yo responder por responder pero no preparar los materiales de apoyo que
a veces funciona bueno sale sale bastante bien bastante bien me acaba de ir bien del todo cuando
se lo había probado pero bueno bueno aquí tendrías nueve tres y estarías en la curva lo que te quiero
decir es poco se ve lo que te quiero decir pero no no se ve al final tú el efecto escala te va a
hacer que tú puedes aquí tener a mejor unos tres malos la curva es más escarpada y allí como es un
gráfico de 503 600 realmente no se ve de acuerdo no se ve quedan las montañitas quedan como más
disimuladas entiendes realmente es queda completamente sin sin sin que se note vale que ese es un poco
el tema solo quiero decir no no me ha salido el todo pero pero bueno eso es un poco la idea a ver
si tampoco es bueno de juego ya está porque estoy aquí tanto tiempo y es eso vale cuando pasa este
tiempo vale decía tener cómo se hace para operar un porfolio se puede activar el porfolio
todos los temas a la vez de alguna manera o señales tema sistema ya está bien por multichar si lo
permite esto es el porfolio trader realmente útil tres eso no es eso realmente tiene solo
sistema sistema te lo montas te lo dices tú la verdad que a nivel de operativa multichar en ese
sentido está mucho mejor tiene un trim manager que es muy chulo porque están truss pero bueno la
verdad que multichar se ha ido mejorando en esta parte y ahora está bastante guapo cuando pasa
cierto tiempo y toca revisión de temas actualizaciones de parámetros en qué casos usáis el
wall forward es una notificación como en la práctica o tal vez revises que no sea por
lo depende el rick depende depende de lo que esté y depende de las revisiones de wall forward pueden
tocar por calendario acordaros si tú has elegido si no si no en una revisión normal porque este
más de flojo lo normal es no hacer wall forward wall forward lo comentaba recomiendo leer por si
alguien no lo ha leído una respuesta que le he dado a rubén aquí esa sección en principio pero
bueno no me ponen preguntas del curso y entiendo que os confundáis le respondí esto a rubén que
la marca del ok vale su pregunta relacionado un poco con el con el wall forward vale respondía ayer
hablaba de optimización de filtros este te recomiendo leer esta esta respuesta de acuerdo
sobre todo para para este caso ahora recordar que el wall forward es estresar y nada más la estrategia
no tiene más finalidad y tan sólo fijar parámetros es una consecuencia que puede usarse o no
y hecho normalmente no se usa decir tú final lo que quieres es ver si la estrategia se adapta al
cambio de tipo de mercado porque voy a tener un cluster wall forward todo el rato hace cortes
distintos en cada cluster con lo cual está obligando al sistema a adaptarse a a optimizar
y probar optimizar y probar que es lo que haces ahora en la realidad porque si tú ahora te pusieras
a pelar un sistema sin wall forward optimizarías y probarías el life pues el wall forward hace eso
constantemente optimiza y te somete eso a pruebas si tú eso te da paso no es el tema
sólo aguanta para eso con más de 50 de wall forward se considera aceptable y los otros datos
que ya conocéis pues es decir al final tapas y es operable entonces una vez el sistema es operable
y te toca una revisión en principio no debería tocar wall forward ahora bien si eso supone la
revisión un cambio importante del sistema pues habrá que validar el cambio se entiende
ahí se depende un poco de que cambiemos la que queda pendiente ya le he contestado y la que no
había contestado es la última de tres me quiero si se ha contestado ahora si se acaba de contestar
antes de esta jose la has contestado tú que no no o que sí de todas maneras tienes la página
en la página pero puede ser que haya o sea a nivel de mql pensaba que tiene tiene como ados
buscarlos y tal nosotros nos gusta demasiado yo sé que hay gente que tiene herramientas de backtips
que no están mal son externas a meta tele que es lo bueno que tiene meta tele permite escalar
es buscar cosas ahí y ver a ver si iberá y si os da algo vale bien bueno vamos con los
cortes vamos con los cortes a ver déjame mirar aquí que tenía varias cosas abiertas
el discurso esto ya lo he tocado tengo dos cosas pendientes para empezar para dejar el
corte para el final le dejó el corte para el final como puede ser alguien que lo interese y
después vale hoy voy con esto de regímenes de mercado vale esto lo tenía apuntado desde el
principio y al final pues ha llegado al final pues sí quería darlos cuando hablé del bix el bix
tiene muchas utilidades pero es muy peligroso y muy complicado recordaros en la teoría cuando
se hizo ese ejemplo con el bix que parecía que iba bien y al final se iba a tomar viento vale
porque porque el histórico que se contango que se van guardes o sea es un es un antiguo
complicado de operar porque el índice es muy chulo le puedes coger cosa va muy bien pero tú
no puedes operar el índice tienes que operar futuros o etf hubo un etf que se rompió
no me acuerdo el nombre aberto se acordó supongo que ha salido un momento en fin o sea al final
tiene tiene tiene miga la cosa es cuidado ahora bien el bix también tiene alguna utilidad muy
interesante que es como la estructura de la volatilidad como al final es un indicador de
miedo porque mide el spread de las opciones de los cp 500 y tiene distintos vencimientos tiene
curvas de plazos el cme publica índices vale quizás viendo uno que le llama bix esto está
en la plataforma vale el bix near term estos lo voy a dar y aquí tengo el bix
y esto hay muchos autores hay papers os vamos a dar el paper también hemos visto el ssrn que
tiene o sobre mañana esto es por favor cuando cabe me voy a casa pero subiré todo lo que he
comentado esto hay papers que usan eso como indicador de régimen de mercado pero un poco
de en este caso régimen régimen modo alarma roja modo alarma roja entonces esto es un indicador
muy sencillo que se llama y se me está complicando la cosa porque ya ya suponía que claro hablar tres
pensar que todavía cuando como sufrido tanta tanta tos se que esto no importa pero me hace
gracia explicaros que tengo una gran parte de esto era tenía días en carne viva o sea era
tremendo y ahora pues claro recuperando muchísimo mucho mejor pero por ejemplo cuando como solo de
la excitación o lo que a la comida me da tos todo es claro hablar hablar hablar pues la larga está
a quejarse a veces entonces ese es el tema sé que voy a volver porque parece que sin querer me
había ido elevando la voz vuelvo a nivel bajo eso le llaman a asmr voy a empezar a hacer asmr
si hablaros así sus sus raros a ver a ver qué tal a ver qué tal si podemos ir aguantar bien lo que
os comentaba de los regímenes hay un paper que ya os lo sube como decía mañana y bueno
parece que ya haberlo se ha preparado varios pero bueno el principal que es el precursor
creo que es éste no es bueno se lo subimos a mí pero no es éste era es el el primero y
y vts si buscamos información esto es implied por la directa y term structure vale entonces
hay un paper que se ha subido al srn vale que habla un poco de todo esto ya lo subiré que lo
quiera leer ya los explico simplemente ves divide el bix por diferentes plazos vale y con
esto pues hace distintas el que he visto más veces usado con el de tres meses pero final
para la estructura los futuros acordados que normalmente están en contango también el bix
acuerdo que quiere decir en contango lo vimos en la teoría pero no recuerdo es lo lógico es decir
que el futuro más lejano en el tiempo valga más que ahora porque porque el tiempo solo factor
temporal los tipos interés incorporan un coste recordaros el valor temporal del dinero primera
clase del curso para los no iniciados si alguien iniciado se lo saltó hombre que habéis comprado
el curso yo recomiendo verlo pero ahí hablamos un poco de esto y de otras cosas y lo que digo
esto es lo normal que ahora mismo por ejemplo que pasa tenemos el bix corto plazo a 12 47 y el bix
a tres meses 14 76 en contango lo lógico lo lógico lo normal entonces este indicador y vts que
lo tenemos aquí pues recoge eso está en 0 84 que está por debajo de 1 cuando sube de 1 quiere
decir que el tres meses ha superado a el corto plazo bien eso usualmente pasa en momentos
críticos de mercado entonces esto recomiendo explorarlo probar dos meses para cada uno tiene
que trabajarlo yo sé da un coso hemos hecho un código para que lo podéis trabajar un código
marco no un código ya acabado y ya esto es todo esto es ponos súper bonus de hecho os diría más
esto en el curso hay perfiles de todo tipo de gente que está empezando gente que ha hecho
trevigentes gente que no y gente que ya incluso hacía treviga olímpico y está viendo a ver que
cuento vale y aprovecho para deciros una cosa nosotros hemos en este tiempo hemos revisionado
prácticamente todos los vídeos en el curso hay cosas hay perlas de muchísimo valor lo que pasa
que no están no digo ojo voy a decir una perla es decir está todo comentado por ahí está hablado
porque yo hablo y hablo y hablo y he soltado cosas de mucho valor de acuerdo y el material al final
que hemos dado es una locura es una locura mucho más de lo que pensábamos ahora de entrada porque
somos así es todo el material sólo sólo lo de status y concept es una bomba todo ese material
ahí con el excel aquel que os dio el análisis realmente ahí hay muchísimo material para trabajar
y seguir aprendiendo pues el curso que hay que seguir aprendiendo esto no acaba no acaba ni mucho
menos hoy y cuando acabas hay que seguir trabajando permanente bien después de este rollo que venía
al caso pero no sé por qué aprovecho para hidratar venía el caso por lo que os decía en este caso
este vts esto podemos considerarlo un nivel avanzado podemos considerarlo un nivel avanzado
entonces si sois principiantes y demás mirarlo claro que sí entenderlo pero tampoco os lo vais
locos vale tampoco nos vais locos entonces nada más entonces lo que os decía os hemos hecho un
para os lo enseño para valorar y para estudiar hay muchos códigos como por ejemplo el que
dimos el buscador de entradas también bastante potente pienso yo pensado con que crezca y lo
adaptéis es esta más desarrollado que este pero aún así es un marco es un ejemplo de cómo trabajar
estas cosas no es directamente ya el sistema hecho lo mismo aquí aquí hemos planteado un código marco
para analizar regímenes de mercado para que nosotros trabajéis y para valorar el vts y mostraros
si quiero utilidad o no vale y lo hemos hecho de una manera simple que nos ha parecido razonable
y creemos que es así y hasta aquí está el código al mismo tiempo pues hemos incorporado más maneras
de mirar el régimen manera super fácil una media móvil el adx vale y y como os digo la
volatilidad mediante el el vtr este entonces al final hemos creado aquí unos case que definen
un tipo de mercado el vayan hall alcista no volátil quiere decir que está por encima de la media y el
adx por encima de su umbral ahora lo miramos en el gráfico hace está volátil en el mercado por
encima de la media el adx por encima del umbral pero el mercado está volátil es decir el y y y y vtn
y vts perdón ya diré me no y vtn y este eso tiene ese venga pues vamos veces y veres vale y vts pero
no sé por qué tengo en la cabeza bueno aquí está volátil con eso disparado no tienes el adx
negativo y no volátil es decir el mercado no tiene tendencia porque la de x está indicado
que se ala podríamos decir que es lateral es decir lateral el adx te puede decir eso con la
volatilidad baja y la de x con la volatilidad alta o sea el adx bajo pero la volatilidad alta
luego bajista y no volátil que quiere decir bajista pues por debajo de la media pero con
tendencia de marcador adx y así y luego al final hemos puesto el mercado volátil el mercado no
volátil o sea sólo la volatilidad sólo el y vts en falls o entró y hasta pero esto como os pongo
aquí arriba puede crecer realmente hemos puesto 6 pero se pueden plantear más escenarios por
ejemplo media alcista pero el adx bajista que quiere decir por debajo del umbral es más que
correcto y viceversa es decir se puede plantear distintos escenarios estos son los típicos porque
la de x bajista como pongo aquí que no sé si es lo más correcto prácticamente es lateral pero se
puede plantear distintos escenarios esto al final si hacemos aquí una sencilla para que lo veáis
lo había hecho antes porque nos ha guardado esto sólo sale el largo porque es el spy
de 0 a 8 esto que dura 0 coma segundos diario vale nos va a decir que el que más gana es el 0 es
decir vayan hall pero no es la que mejor es que lo tiene pero me interesa sobre todo que veáis
acordaros que el 7 y el 8 eran el volatilidad volatilidad y fijaros que el volatilidad gana
245 y volatilidad gana sólo 17 con las más operaciones es decir como claramente confirma
vale que ahora voy a poner el volatilidad y además se podía separar el set up de entrada y salidas
y todo esto está hecho para mostrar simplemente mostrar simplemente el ejercicio o sea está la
misma que la planta para salir decir esto compra cuando la verdadera está alta y viene cuando
los fijaros cómo demuestra claramente que comprar cuando este indicador se dispara cuesta
caro casi no gana y de hecho depende cómo pierde porque fijaros aquí que ya se empieza a disparar
aquí da una señal de aviso pero aquí ya en la primera caída ya estaba a punto de romperse por
un poco por no nada se no lo compra antes de hecho aquí ya corta y para mí disparé compra y al final
se mantiene altos aquí que ya está recuperado para que vuelva a bajar comprar y entonces la
mayoría de veces suponen tres perdeores comprar cuando eso está alto de hecho fijaros que su
porontaje de aciertos es el bueno es el 65 pero es que gana es que al final gana un poco pensaba
que me salieron perdidas a ver todo esto cuando era extrañado para ser el régimen de mercados
de cinco o bral 1 15 se brade que será 15 no se puede mercado 8 sí sí bueno pues igual sale
sale sobre todo fijaros la diferencia lo que decía con el otro ahora pasamos al otro al comprar
justamente cuando está bajo y mantener y fijaros el cambio ya tenemos también 105 operaciones otra
cosa realmente también pierde que no tiene ningún criterio eso es un evaluador no sale por ningún
criterio sólo sale cuando la barra tira su claro aquí fijaros como la mayoría de veces también
tiene tres perdeores lógicamente aquí porque aquí aquí sí que sale pero vuelve a entrar muy
rápidamente o sea la señal de alerta no le dura nada rápidamente vuelve y vuelve a caer se vuelve
a salir va un poco persiguiendo la presión está en este lateral pero al final es que es una
corrección que es corrección no es especialmente grave al final sí que es verdad que falla mucho
al final está sí que llegaba y justo al nivel para marcar el peligro pero al final no había
peligro volvía el mercado estaba fuerte como aquí ha llegado se ha cercado pero ha vuelto y al final
aquí pues acaba entrando y se queda comprado así que comprado al final te muestra claramente como
es un indicador de peligro muy claro muy claro vale también también lo vemos en otros
también vemos por ejemplo que el carlos que hay otro que pierde hay dos que pierden el 2 y el
4 ahora vamos a ver que son así está volátil cuidado el alcista volátil el alcista pero con
esto disparado te pierde dinero es el que perdía vale pero es que fijaros fijaros que se lo pongo
arriba y a nosotros no lo vais a ver pero es que es posible verlo todo claro es imposible verlo
todo si vemos una cosa no vemos la otra a ver si lo puedo poner así me la voy a ponerlo así
aunque se vea un trozo ya me ya me vale ya me vale vale es el 2 el 4 no 4 2 pero el 2 alcista
volátil pero fijaros que su homólogo es alcista no volátil ser 1 es 42 42 y el claramente vuelve a
demostrar que el 1 acaba confirmando y el cuadro va a ser lo mismo el 4 es con el adx por debajo es
decir lateral y volátil otra vez volátil vuelve a perder y su homólogo adx no volátil es el 3 que
es el segundo gana gana bastante 134 vale el lateral gana gana cuando el adx cae comprar ahí
le da bastante esto simplemente es un analizador habría que contemplar más escenarios de salir
de maneras distintas un poco pero fijaros que si ya miramos ratios de retorno riesgo la cosa ya
no queda tan clara y el que da mejor es 3 por ejemplo el que da mejor es 3 en este caso por
tsi que es este del lateral y no volátil es decir es extraño es decir es extraño es comprar ahí
comprar cuando está lateral y no volátil es extraño pero tiene sentido porque al final si el mercado
está lateral pero no el indicador de volatilidad no marca peligro lo normal que va a hacer la bolsa
por subir pues ahí es un buen momento para entrar o se está marcando un buen set up porque el
problema el problema es que la problema que aquí para evaluar eso sale a entrar la salida igual
entonces entonces al final cuando corta se sale cualquiera de ellos es decir si se corta la adx
sale entonces está entonces aquí necesita que los que los 2 entonces el 3 es lateral que quiere
decir que ignora la tendencia es decir aunque esté por debajo de la media compra igual este
ignora la tendencia se ignora estar por debajo por encima de la media podría haberse complementado
distinto pero pero ve lo que compensa decir sólo opera sólo con la de x cuando la de x no esté
disparado compras es así no exacto cuando el mercado en tendencia menos 1 es decir cuando el
mercado esté compra y se sale cuando pueden estar largos falls si cualquiera de los 2 tienen
que ser los 2 tru claro pero ese es el 3 activado la situación activado el 3 el 3 es este no lo
ves y a la que ya la de x vuelve por arriba es un tanto extraño pero bueno le compensa
cuando la de x se empieza a disparar es una vez entre las paradojas de la de x pero es verdad que
los tramos de tendencia más fuerte se nos va a perder como es aquí ves pero sí que es verdad que
la tendencia como es es una de que es muy lento de 22 decir de un mes es aquí a la que ya está
tendencia fuerte se sale porque porque digamos que está más cerca de acabarse la tendencia
entendéis un poco a la inversa ahora qué pasa cuando hay tantos son fuertes pues se queda fuera
se queda fuera ahora sí aquí ya corrige y vuelve a estar al final lo que ha de centrar un poco en
el mercado descansa es y porque le compensa le compensa antes de ir porque así tiene muy pocos
draudons tampoco es que gane tanto hay otros dos que ganan más le vayan hole y el y el 7 el no
volátil comprar siempre que no que estar comprado mientras no haya volatilidad pero el riesgo le
compensa porque así se sale muy rápido vale pero insisto que esto estoy explicándolo para que
entendáis por qué lo hace no pero el objetivo de esto es es es daros el código que entendáis
un poco distintos mecanismos pueden haber otros recordar que ya os enseñé en un ejercicio es
componer el dax en el de más y de menos se puede evaluar para evaluar probarlo a ver con el de más
y con el de menos para el cista y para bajista hay que mirar los distintos sombrales hay que
trabajarlo esto simplemente era un ejemplo vale hemos hecho otro ejemplo que no acaba de ir tan
para nada es decir al final no deja de no deja de demostrar la validez del y bts para esto vale
porque lo hemos probado con él la volatilidad normalizada probando distintos periodos 60 90 y
sí que sí que un poco lo detecta pero mucho peor vale mucho peor es decir o sea este código de aquí
es exactamente igual que el de la derecha vamos a hacerle también la optimización pero en vez de
usar el y bts para poder usar más código vale de hecho me la voy a cargarle ya más código porque
claro aquí ya puedo meterle pues 30 años para poder meterle más código más histórico entonces
hemos usado el como la volatilidad normalizada haciendo lo mismo es un ratio la volatilidad de
60 contra de 90 buscar un ratio de volatilidad pues probar 60 90 hay que probarlo entonces esto
ya hay que hay que trabajarlo no lo hemos trabajado porque repito el objetivo era daros el código
pero aquí podemos hacer la misma prueba que va a tardar un poquito más pero muy poco igualmente y
veréis veréis lo que nos da en este en este caso aquí vemos otra vez lógicamente el que más ganas
se va en hall vemos que el 8 gana más que el 7 pero así gana muy parecido es decir no hay una
gran diferencia hay una gran diferencia vale es decir no parece no de hecho gana el volátil más
que no acaba de no acaba de tener sentido habría que ver habría que ver un poco lo que se va que
hay que jugar con los términos vale porque ese ratio cambia mucho de si le pones a ver qué jugar
eso con el umbral con las dos cosas pues sé que el umbral se ha necesario más elevado es
complicado sí que cuando ves el dibujo le ves le ves que tiene que tiene cierto sentido pero no
acaba de no acaba de tirar así con el volátil con el volátil que es el 8 no el 8 debería haber
momento aquí sí que ahora se ha caído se ha caído más se ha caído más ahora puede ser que
con este 1 1 pero digo es una sobre optimización en el final no deja de ser un intento por por
enseñaros lo que queremos decir es simplemente decir poniendo 08 060 parece que a lo mejor pues
puede ir mejor pero ya digo es solo para que tendáis la idea para que tendáis la idea que sí
aquí sí que el 8 ahora vez aquí sí que se ha penalizado la volatilidad sólo por poner 1 1 pero
aquí es muy sensible al indicador de la tr entonces pero aquí sí que nos ha salido ya poco lo lógico
que el 8 más volátil gana menos el 7 gana más tiene tiene tiene un poco más sentido tiene un
poco más sentido el vallanjol sigue siendo el mejor y así con más histórico por tsi en este
caso sí que el vallanjol gana tanto gana tanto que le compensa le compensa el riesgo y no tiene
ningún tipo de problema porque además es que no le no le está contando el del lado porque no ha
salido no sé por qué no ha salido porque debería salir no en el código tiene salir las barrochar
creo porque no sale no contemplado el trade en el optimizador porque está abierto abierto
no ya está puesto pero al estar abierto no le ponemos hasta ayer y entonces lo volvemos a hacer
entonces ya porque no le ha contado porque no le ha contado al cierre de trade entonces ese es el
pequeño pequeño es igual y nos digo que esto sigue sin contar no sé por qué no lo cuenta no lo entiendo
no lo cuenta y no marca tres cerrados pero no sé por qué no cuenta la verdad no lo entiendo no
entiendo por qué no cuenta el drogón si si lo ha cerrado pero no le cuenta el drogón se lo ha
boqueado sí sí porque mirar el drogón ahí está cuenta bueno sale éste que no cuenta la intradía
no cuenta la intradía bueno es es falso totalmente porque no es gigantesco como habéis visto ahí
es que lo yendo ese el siguiente sería este en este caso es el 1 o vendría el
7 bueno acista no volátil es bastante lógico acista no volátil o vendría el 7 que es no
volátil sale lógico sale lógico es decir sale lógico y el peor el 2 que es el altista volátil
el cista volátil el 5 bajista y no volátil es decir no comprar en bajista y no volátil no le
no le no le gustan a lo que sea no volátil es bajista bueno esto es lo que tenía en cuanto en
cuanto al régimen pero lo voy a dejar guardado así alberto y vamos con los cot vamos con los cot
vamos a hacerlo breve porque sólo es una y media veo que se está aguantando la mayoría yo
sé aguantar es aguanto vamos a hacer brevemente los los cot previamente pero bien bien hecho
un segundo que voy a abrir porque el aire ya no va se me ha abierto aquí en otro sitio pero yo
ahora mismo lo desplazo inmediatamente vale los cot os voy a dar todo lo que tengo sobre los cot
porque había mucho interés no sé exactamente motivo pero había mucho interés y por lo tanto
voy a satisfacer vuestra curiosidad nosotros tenemos ahora mismo tres estrategias diseñadas
que no son estrategias están en todas en preproducción no se han acabado nunca porque
no viene el caso de operar en futuros y aún así sólo lo operaríamos en una cuenta muy grande ya
muy diversificada lo digo para para todos vosotros es decir no sería un tercer sistema de acuerdo
sería como mínimo un décimo sistema vale son sistemas que van normalmente en veras semanales
vale porque los cot es un dato que viene en semanal primero repito que lo subiré todo al
discord mañana lo subiré todo al discord mañana pero yo os explico aquí lo que tenemos vale de
momento os subiré esto que hay tres artículos directamente de la web para que os veáis vale
porque es el mejor sitio donde ir a leerlo me parece absurdo hacer el pdf cuando está online vale
conoce los cot vale aquí explico que son los cot estos de 2017 totalmente en vigor hay un ejemplo
hablo de los cot 3c eso que los publica patatín patapa vale y luego los sistemas aquí están
algunos explicado yo explico los otros no está todo porque no se ha publicado no es público
explico el cot index vale que es lo que se basa la mayoría de sistemas vale el cot index no deja
de ser una especie de estocástico de los cot es decir normalizar los cot el cot index es normalizar
los cot ahora veréis que es eso y explico un sistema muestro unos datos vale estos los subiré
el disco no hace falta ahora ni que os fijéis en la dirección en nada porque los subiré todo
el disco vale que la estáis viendo pero no hace falta porque los subiré vale aquí la segunda parte
y demás esto por un lado en cuanto a la documentación esos dos sistemas los que vais a ver ahora aquí
con estrategia 1 el 2 es este artículo este artículo de traders no es el que hemos desarrollado
creo que no es impecable porque hay cosas que hay que interpretarlas y demás por ejemplo more
management no lo implementamos pero está bastante desarrollado y ahora sí os doy el código que
hicimos nosotros lo hicimos nosotros el cot 2 y el cot 3 es el cot de kauffman ahora los veremos
vale vamos con el cot 1 que son los dos de los artículos que veréis en web el cot 1 primero los
cot este indicador que veis son los que os decía eso esa forma que habéis visto es el comercial
hecho con 55 semanas que es un año es decir el saldo de los comerciales como hace un estocástico
pero las cosas hay que entenderlas un estocástico hace lo mismo cuando está arriba quiere decir que
está en el máximo de el periodo que está estipulando pues esto es lo mismo cuando está
aquí que está en el periodo máximo que un año el saldo de los cot vale el saldo de los cot y
ese es el de los pequeños especuladores en los artículos iniciales explico que es un cot
comercial que es un non comercial y que es un pequeño procurador no voy ahora a recrearme
mucho en eso porque no tenéis los artículos y quiero lo sepa pero los comerciales se consideran
las manos fuertes es un poco el pequeño procurador somos nosotros los pardillos es un poco la idea y
los non comerciales son los que consideran los que fans eso es un poco la teoría la diferencia
entre estos comerciales los que fans es que los comerciales utilizan el futuro como cobertura
tienen que tener el activo en posesión y se están cubriendo y el otro el jefe no por eso
es uno u otro pero ya digo es igual eso al final da un saldo y ese saldo se hace un cot index
y aquí están bruto que estos datos están todos aquí es decir estos cot están todos aquí publicabas
este esto con net position esto es de tres sessions sólo tenéis ya esto si ahora aquí buscáis
edit language cot net position este indicador existe la plataforma no tenéis vosotros pues si
buscáis en aquí co yo tengo más porque tengo varios propios pero veréis que tenéis ya muchos
y os podéis abrir pues leer el código ver cómo está hecho como siempre son datos fundamentales
esto lo coge de reuters y lo y lo grafica vale entonces ahí está hecho eso ya lo tenéis y aquí
vos ves los saldos es el porcentaje que tiene cada uno de todos estos son indicadores que ya están
y que tú no puedes hacer tú no puedes que ya está toda esta información que veis aquí está
disponible la tienes que montar lógicamente tiene que ser un futuro que publique esos datos estos
no lo publican por tanto no hay datos si no los publica por nada obvio y nosotros que hemos hecho
pues el cot index con esos datos hemos hecho el cot index que los datos son estos esto que tú quieres
aquí ves arriba el no comercial y abajo ves el index son comercial ves cuando baja pues se
quiere la parte baja cuando sube de 52 semanas pues se ve es este tiene puesta las bandas de
son nuestras también y ya está pero es que la información saldo disponible que hace ese sistema
ese sistema en sí usa la idea de rullero pero realmente no tiene nada realmente la idea de
rullero es la idea más básica de los cot vale es decir simplemente tienes un trigger arriba y
abajo es un periodo que nosotros damos 55 semanas no aconocieron sabes si tienes un
periodo para salir mal centra esto sí que quiero recordar que era de rullero sólo va largo y sólo
usados comerciales de los pequeños no usan los no comerciales vale entonces al final
simplemente compra cuando el cot de la barra anterior que es la semana anterior tiene el cot
comercial el índice anterior está por debajo del tigre y las siguientes a por encima eso se
podría haber hecho con un cross over entiendo eso justamente es un crossover si le pones si
cot in this crossover a no perdón perdón perdón que me estoy leyendo eso me pasa por
leer rápido como funciona esto si en la semana anterior el comercial estaba por debajo del c
trigger 70 es decir no está sobrecomprado se entiende y el índice de los especuladores de
esta barra es mayor que el s trigger que es el inverso es decir que 30 compró en un stop long
que no deja de ser el vamos a las horas vuelvo vuelvo a revivir y empiezo y empiezo que mientras
lo leía digo no me cuadra compra cuando se sobre compra el comercial vale compra cuando se sobre
compra en la barra anterior es decir cuando supera 70 y los especuladores están por debajo
de la venta porque porque se considera que los pequeños no están nunca en el lado bueno por
lo tanto cuando los pequeños están comprando el están abajo están en mínimos compra es decir
compra cuando éste entra en la banda arriba y éste la banda abajo esto es como compra y sale sale
de dos maneras por lo que se había dicho antes por la silla contraria vale es decir simplemente
cuando se sale cuando es menor que la de arriba y el otro cuando los dos son se sale o en un
stop que es el mínimo de cinco barras son cinco semanas vale sólo haces sólo haces nada más semanal
es muy sencillo esto funciona bueno no va mal en muchos futuros muchos futuros no va mal no en todos
el número de operaciones pues que no es poco en los de bolsa en general va bien pero digo
a lardes de sistemas estos sistemas no se optimiza nada y cualquier análisis se hace conjunto
conjunto siempre se habrá que meter todos los futuros en tal y analizarlo a lo mejor probar
la salida por cuatro o cinco semanas eso sí pero con un montón de futuros dentro está ahí en
todos acciones está ganando creo que el daun son suele ir muy bien con con algunos generales y
pero hay otros que pierde el petróleo no va casi ninguno en el petróleo no va casi ninguno
no me acuerdo mal bueno ahí usted ya usted ya en el oro algunos sí que va a otros no bueno
este parece que sí a ver sólo va largo está pensado más para vos sólo va largo pero es
también petróleo en oro va bastante bien bueno eso es uno para el código lo trabajáis lo que si
queréis pero existe una anécdota al final estos sistemas como puso los artículos sirven para
validar si hay algo no para mí es evidente que cualquier tema esto demuestra que va hay algo
porque entender cómo es el con que no lo explicado muy breve vale los con se publican al cierre de
los viernes pero son datos recogidos hasta martes son datos recogidos hasta martes y tú por lo tanto
te va a dar la señal aquí cierre de esta vela esta semana va a coger el dato ahora no ahora va a
acabar la semana te va a coger el dato no cabe si va al señal te va a comprar la apertura de
la siguiente vela bueno te va a poner el esto para entrar si le toca entrar central lunes o
cuando sea el martes va a quedar la entrada porque va a quedar toda la semana puesta el final pues
es el máximo y te va a entrar con datos y hasta el cierre del viernes no va no va a cambiar la
señal hasta el cierre del viernes no va a cambiar vamos de semana en semana a mí el viernes me da
señal de comprar me compra vamos a suponer el lunes y yo hasta el viernes ahí voy feliz de la
vida se va a hacer mucho riesgo de sólo para complementar carteras esta versión es una versión
totalmente propia que no deja de ser un ejercicio de curioso por experiencia de seguir muchos años
donde me planteé digo que los no comercia los no comercias son los que más correlación tienen
con el precio si tú ves aquí el gráfico de no comercial vas a ver este que tiene una bastante
correlación con el precio cuando el precio sube se sube cuando el precio baja baja se nota
tendencias más o menos moderadas digo este pez ves ahí mínimo para arriba para arriba para arriba
satura lateral suele ir bastante tú analizas la correlación es indicador este tiene bastante
correlación entonces me planteé hacer algo con él no con él al revés siguiendo el precio al
inverso de los otros hice unas reglas es un ejercicio didáctico que compra compra cuando es
mayor que el set trigger en este caso es mayor que 10 cuando sale de abajo sale de abajo de la
banda del coche es decir compra aquí además le exijo que este sea positivo porque el saldo
de no comercias por debajo de cero se considera bajista para el mercado es entonces de cuando
que este saldo sea positivo para una tarrela ya digo basada en ella son bastantes que esté
que sea o sea que sea mayor que el set trigger de 10 pero menor que 90 es decir que cuando ya
esté sobrecomprado no compre no compre y que sea positivo y además que el índice sea mayor que
antes anterior es el que el índice demuestra que esté subiendo que haya tendencia en ese momento
compra tiene a favor un poco de seguimiento de precio y el corto al revés pero es que en el
corto no van casi ninguno en cambio el largo va bastantes y y bueno para salir pues tiene
tiene un canal también lo mismo con el peraute anterior que usaba el rullero y también tiene
la señal contraria pero en esta no hay tantas reglas simplemente que cuando cruza el non
comercial cruza por debajo del de 90 cuando vuelve de arriba se sobrecompra y sale se sale o cuando
es menor que decir que eso es como una seguridad por si no ha llegado a cruzar cuando vuelve a
entrar en sobrecomprar se sale o también si entra en negativo y esto y lo inverso al comprar
claro esto opera muchísimo pero muchísimo al seguir un poco el precio pero muchísimo
fatal fatal pero bueno por el largo en muchos tiene tiene profisator positivo y bueno sí sí que
demuestra que tiene cierto sentido esto para nada recomiendo seguir investigándolo yo lo lo hice
como un ejercicio didáctico es aquí en el largo aquí sí que hay bastantes operaciones en el largo
en la mayoría hay muchos que va largo en el corto pero es que en el petróleo tampoco debe
ir porque costaba mucho que funcionara nada pot igual este sí mira para no tampoco tampoco
en el natural es bastante curioso porque era era un futuro que es súper bajista de aquí
hay mucho problema con el conocido con tanco van guardes en todo esto que os he contado
natural gas en este como era y ves este curiosamente en el gas natural funciona
funciona razonablemente bien pero creo que también funciona este que es solo largo
sonaba igual la otra porque hay varios vale bien es la primera versión vale en
los dos versiones yo los códigos los voy a dar todos no vamos a hacerme pente de repito
esto es ahí vamos a hacer el paper esto es material de bonus está el código ahí lo podéis
abrir en ese lenguaje y esto lo queríamos dar como bonus no es es código hecho nuestro todo
todo ello es propio y totalmente extra no es un ejercicio un sistema luso sino material de
estudio esto es lo mismo no es un sistema luso vale este es lo mismo vimos el de la revista
y de lo que se comentaba lo programamos puede haber alguna cosa que no esté bien ya digo no
hay que interpretarlas y podría ser que no estuviera bien esto ya los que pilotéis de
programación pues es verlo ahí está el código he saído la revista os damos el artículo y hemos
tratado de ser fieles a su a su idea pero ya digo como siempre en estas cosas explicadas y más en
una revista pues hay cosas que hay que interpretarlas tienes bueno tienes a autor para preguntarle
entonces al final pues ese es el tema este es más complejo tiene dos datas es complicado
pero bueno también lo mismo en algunos van otros no pasa lo mismo que lo comercian en largo bastante
bien corto no tanto bueno pues lo que os digo depende depende de cuáles hay algunos que van
mejor que otros es un poco complicado estamos en las tres horas 26 minutos en en directo
es llegar a los dos en el petróleo pues en el petróleo por ver si va alguno cargando que le
pasa para estar a mucho cargando a mucho cargar tampoco van este el oro es un poco más variable
lo gusta más curiosamente es un poco más le ir a allí en la web acordaros que tenía unos puestos
en su momento lo cual pues ahora podéis ver cómo han ido después interesante esto siempre es un
dato de 2017 creo pues aquí en el oro vuelve en largo pero no en el corto y el gas natural que
siempre me da curiosidad porque el gas natural es un activo realmente complejo cuando lo encuentre
aquí para el corto para bajar mucho es ese día el 2 y el 3 es de cálvaras está en el libro de
cauman es más convencional es verdad que tiene una cosa interesante me gustó probarlo es una
cosa más interesante y tiene realmente muchísimo mérito lo que hace por eso quizá para mí es de
los más destacados porque en este caso sí que al de rullero le implementamos esta salida creo
que ya la llevaba este cambio no lleva nada es simplemente la regla en bruto opera poquísimo
este sí que habría que meterlo en 200 futuros pero muy poco es una vela muy estricta mejor se
podía mirar de buscar a mejor periodos más cortos todo esto que veis offset tal esto es
es una función que pinta en el gráfico directamente vale tres eso no permite que los sistemas pinten
y que eso es un truco es un es un código esto no es nuestro están los foros de tres
así os vendrá y tal lo podéis abrir y utilizar creo que se utilizaba reis era
no esa usa vectores en vez de reis que es más más eficiente usaba vectores entonces al final
esto lo que hace es pintar el mismo código a veces satura poco el ordenador pero es verdad que lo
he ido mejorando entonces que hace el co3 vale que es el que de cauman que es lo que
hace es un poco comprar igual es decir con los cot index tienes el cot index de comerciales
vale de tenerlo todos de comercia de los comerciales y aquí usa el comercial anterior que sea mayor
que hace trigger vale que es mayor que ochenta es decir un poquito parecido al que había de
no bueno será distinto este este compra más bien cuando se sobre compra no eso es entra cuando se
sobre compra pero además esta es la curiosidad no compra en contra del precio es decir le pide
que el cero sea menor que el cierre de tres semanas que haya caído un poco sino no entra
le pide las dos cosas exige este set up es a medio curiosidad de comprar contra porque además
lo realmente destacable es que no tiene nada de salir sale por señal contraria en el sentido
cuando está largo solo sale si el cot es menor que 40 el cot index mientras no pasa eso no se sale
ni mínimos ni máximos ni stop ni nada vale yo aquí tengo puesto pero no está activo si no
recuerdo mal en ese día no tengo en algunos tengo puesto un elemento precreado de tres
veces o no a tener de lo que sea no aquí no hay nada es decir esto está comprando saliendo solo
cuando cae de 40 es una auténtica locura porque no tiene salida no tiene salida es decir va pelo
va pelo y por eso hacen algún futuro que tenga desastres pero realmente son poquísimos en la
mayoría gana dinero en la mayoría con muy pocos trents pero claro es lo que decimos al final es
la misma regla solo utiliza los cot está al final es el que más valida los cot aquí para que este
del nasdaq está en plano podemos decir que ahora solo hay 10 operaciones en el final hay poco
histórico pero en términos general es 77 por ciento de acierto se ha marcado set up de entrada
bastante bueno es verdad que dices hombre claro pero es que la bolsa es esa son activos alcistas
sí sí es verdad hay un sesgo y a favor a un viento de cola pero bueno el oro también ha subido pero
no no tanto y además se aprecia a este sí que lo metes en el gas natural y dices hombre aquí no
puede ser que vaya y efectivamente no va habría que buscar sabría que buscar el contrario para
estos probarlo usamos el código a ver el inverso como en cortos para un activo bajista probar de
salidas pero ya digo es es realmente es realmente destacable porque tienes otros activos que al
final muchos la mayoría de activos a largo plazo y tienden a subir eso es así pero que tiene tiene
muy pocos trades pero es verdad que sí sí que se nota que el set up suele estar bastante afinado
lógicamente no siempre al final oye puede ser un número casual y está el que más opera es el que
hemos hecho nosotros que se puede trabajar y pulir más y todos estos ejercicios no dejan de ser
ejercicios académicos para el mercado y realizarlo y pueden ser filtros y bases para
sistemas porque para mí queda en general queda bastante claro con todos los sistemas cuando los
trabajas bien que sí que es verdad que los co tienen algo predictivo en algo predictivo pero
claro es una señal muy retrasada y claro se tiene un precio se tiene un precio social muy muy lenta
por muy lenta pero sí que sí que parece haber algo algo ahí esto como nos lo habíais pedido
pues ya digo subiré todo este material de los de los co subiré el código y los sistemas y así
os lo dejaré subido repositorio para aquel que lo quiera aprovechar vale no veo preguntas
con lo cual
despido lógicamente con unas palabras de despedida vale que seguramente las mismas
o recordar que se os podía poner el vídeo del final de la teoría recuerdo para insistir en ello
de acuerdo lo dije mucho hasta por el marketing no espero creo que no ha pasado pero por si
alguien todavía queda que pensaba que hacer un curso con nosotros supondía ser al día siguiente
o sea hoy trader algorímico profesional creo que sus expectativas no eran realistas de acuerdo
yo creo que ha quedado un curso realmente potente por cierto por favor la encuesta que os va a llegar
después responderla lo agradezco lo agradezco mucho y leeré todos vuestros comentarios con
mucho interés pero que tenéis que seguir trabajando volver a hacer el curso por favor entero teoría
práctica podéis seguir preguntando trataremos de responder a todo el mundo en el disco por favor
poder ser aquí en la sección de pregunta aquí y aprovechar todo el material hay mucho material yo
tengo la sensación por las preguntas muchas veces que todo el material no se ha visto pasa
nada no entiendo también hay esta parte de la teoría que es verdad que esto aquí parece como
queda escondido pero todas aquí y te abre todo un montón de material de la teoría de acuerdo
materiales que vimos sobre la teoría ves todo cosas que salieron la teoría las daba aquí yo
que sé los grosarios que estaban en los vídeos si no estaban bien aquí en la evaluación todo material
anexo 1 de estadística el material estadística todos aquí hay digo porque tengo la sensación no
me acuerdo quién me lo dijo que no que no había visto esto aquí puso manual extra de análisis
técnico vale todo esto por si alguien no lo había visto quería recordarlo porque sí que una persona
me dijo que lo había visto y tenía la sensación por alguna pregunta que quizá no se había visto
todo este material de teoría que hay aquí y por supuesto el de la práctica yo creo que ahora no
nos queda nada pendiente por subir aparte de lo de hoy aparte de lo de hoy pero así por lo que fuera
pasará a faltar algo por favor hacernoslo saber y por supuesto que no los subiría los
el está tiene bastante potencial sobre todo por el libro pero yo habiendo subido pues por
supuesto mirarlo el de strategy concepts este es muy potente de acuerdo trabajarlo mucho
os recomiendo buscar y por supuesto el buscador de entradas de entradas y salidas todo el material
de filtros creo que al final quedó muy muy completo con algunos todos los doy por desarrollar es decir
no nunca nunca pensábamos que salierais aquí con un montón de sistemas hechos para operar aunque
hay cosas que son para operar o que son casi para operar con 2 3 toques vale pero
como es aquella frase no de que no me des el pescado sino enséñame a pescar no es un poco
eso no sé si era así la frase pero bueno algo es se trata de daros las herramientas yo espero
haberlo conseguido le he puesto todo todo el cariño y quedamos a vuestra disposición recordar los
jueves por favor los directos nada más ahora sí ya que me despido mañana os subiré todo el material
de hoy os mando un abrazo muy fuerte y con esto acaba el curso de técnica grémico un abrazo muy
fuerte y espero veros por los mercados hasta pronto chao